Guys, breathe. Big in, big out, okay? Big in one more, big in. In through the nose. Yeah, and out. Are you just really getting into your sits bones? Okay, are you feeling a little bit relaxed, both of you guys? A little bit?
伙计们，吸气。深吸，深呼，好吗？再深吸一次，深吸。用鼻子吸气。对，然后呼气。你们两个是真的把坐骨坐实了吗？好吧，你们两个现在感觉有点放松了吗？有一点吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Let me just tell you this. I took some of the smart list money and put it in Bitcoin. Wait, what? Wait, it's gonna be fine. Welcome to all new smartless. Smart. Loss.
对，对，对。我跟你们说个事。我拿了一些 Smartless 的资金，投资了比特币。等等，什么？等等，没事的。欢迎收听全新的 Smartless。Smart. Loss（聪明变成亏损）。
Smart. Loss. Smart. Loss. I'm at the office today, so I'm not... Wait, whoa. But I've got a new... What office? You don't have a fucking office. I have an office I've had for a couple years over here.
Smart. Loss。Smart. Loss。我今天在办公室，所以我不……等等，哇。但我有一个新……什么办公室？你才没有狗屁办公室呢。我有间办公室，我在这边用了好几年了。
You don't need to talk all calm like it's no big deal. Let's talk about it. You're really impressed with offices. Yeah, I am. Remember the one we had you never showed up talk about it. You're really impressed with offices. Yeah, I am. Remember the one we had you never showed up in? Yeah, you know why? Because my dad spent 50 years working in an office and I'm an artist, man.
你不用装出一副云淡风轻、好像没什么大不了的样子跟我说话。我们来聊聊这个。你对办公室真的很有执念。对，我是有。还记得我们以前那间你从没露面过的——我们来聊聊这个。你对办公室真的很有执念。对，我是有。还记得我们以前那间你从来不去的吗？对，你知道为什么吗？因为我爸在办公室里干了50年，而我是一个艺术家，老兄。
I'm not playing part of a business. I'm not playing businessman. Oh, let me go in and. Are you storytelling? Are you working out how to story tell? I'm an artist, though, okay? I'm an artist. Wait, okay? I'm an artist. Wait, truly, truly, honestly, how long have you had this?
我才不玩什么商业游戏。我才不装什么商人。哦，让我进去。你是在讲故事吗？你是在琢磨怎么讲故事吗？不过我是个艺术家，好吧？我是个艺术家。等等，好吧？我是个艺术家。等等，说真的，说真的，老实说，你这间办公室租多久了？
I've never heard about this. Couple years. Do you want me to turn the camera around so you can see? Wait, is this where the Beast lives? Yeah, this is where the Beast lives. Hang on. Who's, what's the Beast? I guess we'll wait, listener, just wait.
我从来没听说过这事。好几年了。你想让我把镜头转过去让你看看吗？等等，野兽就住这儿吗？对，野兽就住这儿。等一下。谁是，野兽是谁啊？我想我们还是等着吧，听众朋友们，等着瞧吧。
Will's gotta... Oh, a farmer. No, he doesn't need to bring in, it's not show and tell. Oh, oh, oh, he's got the leather, he's got like the bachelor leather pouch. Look at how unused that meeting space is. What are you talking about? JB, you just forget, I grew up in a serious world.
威尔得去……哦，一个农夫。不，他不需要拿出来，这不是搞展示和讲解。哦，哦，哦，他拿着皮具，他拿着那种单身汉用的皮质小包。瞧瞧那个会议区有多崭新，根本没人用过。你在说什么啊？JB，你就是忘了，我是生活在一个严肃的世界里。
You grew up, so now you're playing make-belief office manager. You've got a company. Yeah, but there's people in my office. You've got an empty meeting space. Dude, it doesn't matter. It's like those people who used to go like, we're going to have all these platforms for content,
你长大了，所以现在你在过家家，假装自己是办公室经理。你有一家公司。对，但我的办公室里有人。你只有一个空荡荡的会议区。老兄，这根本无所谓。这就跟以前那些人似的，他们会说，我们要为内容搭建各种平台，
and we're going to create content. Like, what's the content? You can have, anybody can have a fucking office. Sean could have an office for Christ's sake. I think he does. He's talking to us from, it's just off the kitchen though. By the way, this is true. Ricky's bed is there below his feet
我们要创作内容。拜托，内容到底是什么？谁都能有间狗屁办公室。肖恩都能有间办公室，看在上帝的份上。我想他确实有。他就是在跟我们连线，只不过旁边就是厨房而已。顺便说一句，这是真的。里奇的床就在他脚底下。
Hey, so how is everybody's night So listeners we just or listener sorry, I was a little ambitious there Oh god, I'm doing we we had we dinner again, our Sunday dinner, we haven't had. How long did it, how long had it been? Months? Months. Yeah, like two or three months. Yeah, that was fun, it was good to see everybody.
嘿，大家昨晚过得怎么样？所以听众朋友们，我们刚刚——或者说听众，抱歉，我刚才有点野心勃勃了。哦天哪，我在干嘛。我们——我们又聚在一起吃晚餐了，我们的周日晚餐，我们已经好久没吃了。有多久了，隔了多久了？几个月？几个月。对，大概两三个月。对，挺好玩的，很高兴能见到大家。
It was really good, it was really good, it was really good to see Danny D's. Yeah, the great Dan D's. He's the best, I love him and Don. And Don. That he and Don have are part of our regular crew now. That's really, it's nice. It's nice.
真的很高兴，真的很高兴，很高兴能见到小丹。对，伟大的丹·D。他是最棒的，我爱他和唐。还有唐。他俩现在已经成了我们常聚的死党了。这真的，感觉真好。真好。
Did everybody sleep okay today? Yeah, we're a little tie-tie, yeah? I guess so. I got my PJs on still. Will, do you wear your pajamas to the office? I don't, I could. It's so fast, it's a five minute drive now from my new place. It's great.
大家今天都睡得还好吗？对，我们都有点困恹恹的，是吧？我想是的。我身上还穿着睡衣呢。威尔，你穿睡衣去办公室吗？我才不，但我可以。现在快极了，从我的新住处开车过去只要五分钟。太棒了。
I bet they were very happy to see you. You have not been in there for a while. You're fresh back from your film. I haven't been here in a minute. They were happy to see me and yeah, it was good. I was up super early. I'm still a little jet lagged and still coming down. My closet's all messed up from late nights and stuff.
我敢说他们见到你一定很高兴。你已经好一阵子没去那儿了。你刚从片场拍完电影回来。我有一阵子没来这儿了。他们见到我很高兴，对，感觉挺不错的。我起得超级早。我还有点倒时差，劲儿还没完全过去。因为熬夜什么的，我的衣橱现在一团糟。
So I don't know, just one of those. I woke up the other morning at like 4.45 and I got a coffee and then I was sitting and watching outside and I saw this huge, crazy light being followed by sort of mist. It was kind of cutting through the mist but the light was coming from behind. I looked it up and it turns out it was a rocket
所以，怎么说呢，就是那种情况吧。前天早上大概4点45分我醒了，去买了一杯咖啡，然后我坐在那儿往外看，看到一个巨大、疯狂的光团被某种雾气笼罩着。它有点像是在穿透雾气，但光是从后面照过来的。我查了一下，原来是一枚火箭
being launched from just up the coast here in California. UFO. UFO, it was pretty spectacular to see at like 5.30 a.m. So I've been feeling just a little spacey just kinda coming back to that. Well you're still on Eastern time, so you're still getting up, and I'll bet you were getting up at five in the morning
刚刚从加州这边的海岸发射升空。UFO。UFO，凌晨5点30分看到这个真是太壮观了。所以我的脑子还有点飘忽，刚从那种状态缓过来。好吧，你还在用美东时间，所以你还是起得很早，我敢你在那边
over there, which was two in the morning here. We were doing five in the morning like Monday, Tuesdays, and then immediately switching to nights, and we did that for about three weeks in a row. The littlest thing that I did, Jay, I was there, we had night shoots, and it was two in the morning. Your listener, Sean, was in it as well.
总是早上五点起床，这里其实才凌晨两点。我们周一、周二都要在早上五点开工，然后立刻转为拍夜戏，我们连续大约三个星期都是这样。我做的一点点小事，杰伊，我就在那儿，我们有夜戏，当时是凌晨两点。你们的听众肖恩也在里面。
But like two in the morning, I'm like, okay, bye everybody, I got to go home, and I look back, I'm like, there's Willie still going till like five, six in the morning, it was unbelievable. And then I've got young Denny too. So Denny's been, he's a little bit on New York Times too. So he's like up early and you know, anyway, it's all good. These are great problems to have.
但在凌晨两点左右，我想，好吧，大家拜拜，我得回家了，然后我回头一看，心想，威尔还在那儿干到早上五六点，这简直难以置信。然后我还有年轻的丹尼。所以丹尼也一直……他也有点按纽约时间作息。所以他起得很早，你知道的，总之，一切都很好。这些都是幸福的烦恼。
But it's nice being in California, nice to see everybody. I'm sorry about last night too, I was gonna grab a bite of steak and I forgot I had a dinner because our friend's dog died. Okay, so JB, I'm gonna walk you through this because it a little bit felt like a lie. No, not at all, not at all.
不过能在加州真好，很高兴见到大家。还有，昨晚的事我很抱歉，我本打算去吃一小块牛排，但后来我忘了我有个晚宴，因为我们朋友的狗死了。好吧，JB，我来跟你理一理这件事，因为这听起来有点像是个借口。不，完全不是，完全不是。
Okay, well hang on. And I don't want to meet, I guess it looks like we have a double guest coming up, which we, because we got two squares. Sorry guests. Sorry guests, plural, Jesus. Yeah, and then I want to ask you if you've locked down your car,
好吧，等一下。而且我不想遇到，看起来我们好像要迎来一组双人嘉宾，因为我们屏幕上有两个方块。抱歉，嘉宾们。抱歉，嘉宾们，复数，天哪。对，然后我想问你是不是把你的车定下来了，
and we don't need to say what kind it is. Okay, yes, yes I have. You did? That's a lot. Paul listener. Oh, that's nice. Oh, Bobby Bigdeals at the fucking office got himself a real nice car this weekend.
我们不需要说是什么牌子的。好吧，是的，是的，我已经定下来了。你定了？那可真不便宜。保罗听众。哦，那挺好。哦，在狗屁办公室里发大财的鲍比这周末给自己搞了一辆超级赞的车。
Bobby Bigdeals? Jesus Christ. I know, I know. Let's not go TD. So I mean the big. We're gonna leave it at that. We're gonna go TD. But I said to Sean yesterday,
发大财鲍比？天哪。我知道，我知道。我们别扯到TD（Ted Danson）身上。我是说那个大人物。我们就聊到这儿吧。我们聊聊TD。但我昨天跟肖恩说，
I talked to him in the morning, we were talking about something and I go, oh, you know what? I think that the big boys have stuff after school and they have music and athletic stuff. So I said, you to go get a dinner, grab an early dinner? He goes, yes.
我早上跟他聊过，我们谈了一些事，我说，哦，你知道吗？我觉得大孩子们放学后都有活动，他们有音乐和体育方面的安排。所以我说，你要不要去吃个饭，早点吃个晚宴？他说，好啊。
And then he texts me and he goes, oh, I forgot our friends, we made plans with our friends. I'm like. Yeah, that is true. It felt a little excuse-y, do you know what I mean? No, I swear to God. Because the initial thing was like,
然后他给我发信息说，哦，我忘了我们的朋友，我们跟朋友有约了。我就想。对，那是真的。感觉有点像在找借口，你知道我的意思吗？不，我发誓绝对没有。因为一开始的时候是这样的，
yes, of course I want to go to Jar and have a steak with you. And then I- But didn't you pile on the excuse just now and say that an animal had died as well? It didn't pile on, but- Well, he had a friend, friends of theirs were mainly- Kevin and Carrie, you know, Kevin and Carrie.
对，我当然想去 Jar 餐厅跟你一起吃块牛排。然后我——但你刚才不是顺势加了个借口，说有一只动物也死掉了吗？我不是在堆砌借口，但是——好吧，他有个朋友，他们的朋友主要是——凯文和卡莉，你知道的，凯文和卡莉。
And they said, he said that they lost their dog. I said, well, maybe we can help them find it. Find it. Good will. Which is a ripoff of an old Norm MacDonald joke, by the way. So wait, so they lost their dog and they needed you and Scotty to sit around them
他们说，他说他们的狗丢了。我说，那也许我们可以帮他们找找。找找。好心肠。顺便说一句，这抄袭了诺姆·麦克唐纳的一个老笑话。等等，所以他们弄丢了狗，然后需要你和斯科蒂围在她身边
and eat so they could feel better. You know, the doggies like a family member. JB, have you tried this bar? Yeah, I have, it's not bad. It's pretty good, right? Yeah, you can mention it, maybe get some free ones. Okay, you know, I'm good for six bucks. I'll wait till you take a bite.
吃东西，这样他们就能感觉好受点。你知道的，狗狗就像家庭成员一样。JB，你尝过这个能量棒吗？对，我吃过，还不错。挺好吃的，对吧？对，你可以提一下，说不定能免费送你一些。好吧，你知道的，我这6块钱还是掏得起的。我等你咬一口再说。
The Bear Bell, the Bear Bell bars, they're really good. All right, listener, today, we don't have some fishy, flashy, fancy celeb type. Uh-oh. Not today. Today we have got not one, but two people who make the flashy, fancy types. They are two of the most important people
这个熊贝尔，熊贝尔能量棒，真的很好吃。好了，听众朋友们，今天我们没有那些花里胡哨、闪闪发光的大明星。哦哦。今天没有。今天我们迎来的不是一位，而是两位打造出那些花里胡哨大明星的幕后推手。他们是当今行业里最举足轻重的两个人。
in the industry today. Period. Full stop. Entertainment industry. Okay? Okay, okay. Individually. He's not the industry. Okay? Okay, okay. He's not the only industry in the world, okay? I apply, alright. But individually, individually, they've been behind such movies as
句号。完了。娱乐行业。好吧？好吧，好吧。单独拎出来。他可不是整个行业。好吧？好吧，好吧。他不是世界上唯一的行业，好吧？我适用，好吧。但是单独来看，单独来看，他们曾操刀过以下电影：
Birdman, The Big Short, The Revenant, The Social Network, Moneyball, Captain Phillips, Austin Powers, Boogie Night, Seven. Together, they have combined to bring us such films as Beetlejuice, Beetlejuice, Wonka, Dune, Part 2, and Barbie. Let's find out how these two are able to bring us so much incredible entertainment. Please meet the co-chairs and CEOs of Warner Brothers Motion Picture Group, Pam Abdee and Michael DeLuca. On SmartList.
《鸟人》、《大空头》、《荒野猎人》、《社交网络》、《点球成金》、《菲利普斯船长》、《王牌大贱谍》、《不羁夜》、《七宗罪》。他们强强联手，为我们带来了《阴间大法师2》、《旺卡》、《沙丘2》以及《芭比》这样的电影。让我们来一探究竟，看看这两位是如何为我们带来如此多精彩绝伦的娱乐作品的。有请华纳兄弟电影集团的联席董事长兼首席执行官，帕姆·阿布迪和迈克尔·德·卢卡。欢迎来到 SmartList。
Good morning. We're going to have a couple of smart folks come on and talk to us for fucking once. This is cool. I had to hold my laughter in. Oh my God. I want to say Pam's still at home. Mike you're at the office. I am.
大家早。我们终于要请到几位聪明绝顶的大人物来跟我们聊聊天了。这太酷了。我刚才得拼命忍住不笑。天哪。我想说帕姆还在家里。迈克你在办公室。我是。
I'm in the office. You were both in the office. We have two offices. We have an office we share and then we have a spillover office. We need to do solo things. Pam's in the spillover office. These are people with two offices. So in all of Warner Brothers, you only have two offices.
我在办公室。你们俩都在办公室。我们有两个办公室。我们有一个共享的办公室，然后我们还有一个溢出办公室。我们需要处理各自的事情。帕姆在溢出办公室。这就是拥有两个办公室的人。所以在整个华纳兄弟，你们就只有两个办公室。
In the shared office, do you have one of those his and her desks where you're looking at each other? No, we thought about it, like an old movie. We're not diagonal. We are. Like an old Howard Hawks movie, like a Ben Hecht scream play where the desks in the newsroom are together. But we went, I think, a more realistic,
在那个共享办公室里，你们有那种“他的/她的”双人办公桌，可以四目相对吗？没有，我们考虑过，就像老电影里那样。我们不是对角线摆放。我们是。就像老霍华德·霍克斯的电影，比如本·赫克的剧本，新闻室里的办公桌是拼在一起的那种。但我们觉得，更现实的做法是，
we're catty-cornered. We did have that for a second, didn't we? Jason and I had an office for a while, for a couple years where we faced each other, and he would always complain, as you could just tell this morning, that I was never there. Again, my dad was in an office.
我们的办公桌是拐角相对的。我们之前确实那样摆过一会儿，对吧？我和杰森以前有一间办公室，用了好几年，我们的办公桌是面对面的，他总是抱怨——就像你今天早上能看出来的那样——说我从来不在办公室。再说一次，我爸就在办公室工作。
What happened to the company? What happened to the company? It went belly up. Like a lead balloon, right? Your shitty ideas sunk it. Hey, welcome to Smart List. Wow, this is an honor for us. We're super fans.
那家公司后来怎么了？那家公司后来怎么了？彻底破产了。像铅球一样直往下沉，对吧？你那些烂点子把它搞垮了。嘿，欢迎来到 SmartList。哇，这对我们来说真是个荣幸。我们都是你们的超级粉丝。
Pam and I have threatened to do this for a long time. I'm so glad we finally found some time from your very busy schedule to do this. Thank you. Collectively, individually and collectively, you two are responsible for some of the greatest pieces of entertainment that people have enjoyed across this country ever. It's true. It's really cool, so impressive.
帕姆和我威胁要做这档节目已经很久了。我很高兴我们终于从你们百忙之中抽出了时间来做这件事。谢谢你们。你们俩，无论是集体还是个人，都为这个国家的广大民众奉献了有史以来最伟大的一些娱乐作品。真的。这真的很酷，太让人印象深刻了。
It is really impressive. Thank you. It is. Now, but what is unique, listener, is that usually the people who are driving these factories of incredible entertainment. It's usually just one person. But this is a pair, this is a duo,
确实令人印象深刻。谢谢你们。确实如此。不过，听众朋友们，独特的地方在于，通常驱动这些伟大娱乐制造工厂的人。通常只有一个人。但这却是一个搭档，这是一个双人组，
and this isn't the first time that you guys have done it. You came from, tell the audience where you started to work on your duoness. Well, I got to meet Pam. I was at this company New Line in the 1990s. It was my first job, actually. Oh, I'm company! Out of a... This is a company! company New Line in the 1990s. It was my first job actually. I was there as an intern in
而且这已经不是你们第一次搭档了。你们是从哪儿开始培养出这种双人默契的，讲给观众听听吧。好吧，我认识帕姆的时候。我90年代在新线公司。其实那是我的第一份工作。哦，我是公司的人！出身于……这是一家公司！90年代的新线公司。其实那是我的第一份工作。我1985年从纽约大学毕业去那里实习，
85 from NYU so I had been at New Line for a long time and Pam worked for this company Jersey Films which of course produced Pulp Fiction and so many great films in the 90s. St. Endivido and Michael. Schamburg and Stacey Cher. Yep. Many of my people moved to Jersey. This is an ongoing dumbass bit, some Italian guy in the back wings that likes to comment. Sorry, push through it. That's okay. So that's where I met Pam.
所以我在新线待了很长时间，而帕姆当时在杰西电影公司（Jersey Films）工作，这家公司当然制作过《低俗小说》和90年代那么多伟大的电影。斯坦·恩迪维多和迈克尔。尚伯格和斯泰西·谢尔。没错。我的很多人都跳槽去了杰西。这是一个没完没了的蠢笑话，后面后台有个意大利人在那儿喜欢插话。抱歉，继续说吧。没关系。所以我就是在那儿认识帕姆的。
Pam, Jersey Films produced a couple of movies for New Line. That's where I met Pam. We became best friends. She's from Jersey. I'm from Brooklyn. We're united on all things Italian food. It's the Holland Tunnel apart. And movies.
帕姆，杰西电影公司为新线制作了几部电影。我就是在那里认识帕姆的。我们成了最好的朋友。她是泽西人。我是布鲁克林人。我们在意大利美食上有着共同的语言。只隔了一条荷兰隧道。还有电影。
Yep. And then we had a chance. We switched jobs many times. I went from being an exec to being a producer. She became an executive paramount. I produced for her. Then when I became an executive again after producing at MGM, I invited Pam to work with me and then we've been an executive team ever since.
没错。然后我们有机会。我们换过很多次工作。我从高管变成了制片人。她成了派拉蒙的高管。我为她制作电影。后来我在米高梅担任制片人后再次成为高管，我邀请帕姆来和我一起工作，从那以后我们就一直是一个高管团队。
It's just like, but so then again, for the listener, there's, you can either be selling stuff or you can be buying stuff. And that's like a big, big difference, you know? One, obviously you're sort of like doing the dog and pony show and selling your wares. And the other one, you get to sit back in the chair, fold your arms and say, sell me, let the other one, you get to sit back in the chair, fold your arms,
这就好比，所以话说回来，对于听众来说，要么你在卖东西，要么你在买东西。这真是一个巨大、巨大的区别，你知道吗？一方面，显然你有点像是在搞路演卖艺，兜售你的商品。另一方面，你可以舒舒服服地坐在椅子上，双臂抱胸说：推销给我听听，
and say, sell me, let me hear what you've got, I mean, to overly reduce it. So you guys have done both of that at very, very, very high levels. You're obviously on the premium, elite buying side right now. Is there a side that you like more? I mean, obviously with the selling part,
让另一个人坐在椅子上，双臂抱胸说：推销给我听听，让我听听你有什么好点子，我是说，这有点过于简化了。所以你们俩在非常、非常、非常高的层面上都经历过这两种角色。显然你们现在处于高端、精英的买方阵营。有没有哪一边是你们更喜欢的？显然，在卖方这一边，
you spend more time sort of out there in the trenches and on set sometimes, and on the buying side, you're in a more air conditioned situation. Snacks are better, more consistent. What do you prefer? Well, you know, it's different pleasures. When you're a producer, it's more artisanal, and you're building the project from the ground up
你要花更多时间在战壕里摸爬滚打，有时还得泡在片场；而在买方这一边，你的环境更有空调。零食更好，也更稳定。你们更喜欢哪一个？嗯，你知道的，各有各的乐趣。当你是个制片人时，更像是做手工，你要和导演一起
with the director and you're just so much more intimately involved in just the creative aspects of movie making and it's just a different pleasure. You're kind of part of a family that erupts as the thing starts to take shape. And it's a really wonderful experience and you're with these people for... It's stressy, I bet, yeah?
从头到尾打造这个项目，你更深入地参与到电影制作的创意方面，这是另一种不同的乐趣。随着事情开始成形，你会觉得加入了一个不断壮大的大家庭。这真的是一段美妙的经历，你和这些人在一起……压力一定很大吧，对吧？
Because you're not in control, you're not the buyer. You sing for your supper a little bit more, but we find there's advocacy on both sides. If you're a producer, you're advocating for a financier or a studio to green light you, but even when you have the power of the checkbook, you're still advocating for your boss or the board that you report to to finance
因为你没有控制权，你不是买方。你得为了生计多卖力一点，但我们发现双方都有需要游说争取的地方。如果你是个制片人，你在为资方或电影公司争取开绿灯；但即使你掌握着支票簿的大权，你依然在为你的老板或你汇报的董事会争取资金，
a slate of pictures. There's advocacy in both versions of the job. But the agenda's different. Yeah Pam, I mean you're like, while you're advocating, you need to sort of mind the asset a little bit more on the buying side and on the selling side, you can be a little bit more sort of purist and like no just whatever's better for the film I mean I'm oversimplifying it. But you also know as both having having been
来资助一整批影片。这两种工作都有需要游说争取的部分。但目的不同。对，帕姆，我的意思是，你在游说争取的同时，作为买方，你需要更多地照顾资产本身；而在卖方这边，你可以更纯粹一点，觉得“不，只要对电影更好就行”，我是说我把问题过分简化了。但你们也知道，双方都待过的人
on the other side that you know you you can't bullshit a bullshitter so if somebody comes to you and is like hey this and then you're like hey man I know how it's I know how the sausage. Nobody can tell Pam nobody can tell Pam no no producer is gonna pull the wool over Pam's eyes on a budget. She can literally do both jobs, you know, with her eyes closed. Yeah, my love, I mean Jason knows this
都知道，你骗不了骗子，所以如果有人跑来对你说，嘿，这个怎么样，然后你会说，嘿，老兄，我知道是怎么回事，我知道内幕。没人能忽悠帕姆，没人能忽悠帕姆，没有哪个制片人能在预算问题上蒙蔽帕姆的眼睛。她简直可以闭着眼睛把这两份工作都干了，你知道的。对，亲爱的，杰森懂的，
because Jason and I have produced a movie together and worked together. My first love will always be producing because I just love the grind and being on set, as you guys know, it's just the best. There's nothing like it. Well then, do you miss that? Always, but I love this too. You know, it's just the best. There's nothing like it. Well then do you miss that? Always, but I love this too.
因为杰森和我一起制作过电影，也共事过。我的真爱永远都是制片工作，因为我就是喜欢那种拼搏的感觉，喜欢待在片场，正如你们所知，那简直太棒了。没有什么能与之相比。那么，你会怀念那种生活吗？永远会，但我也很喜欢现在的工作。你知道的，那简直太棒了。没有什么能与之相比。那么你怀念那个吗？永远怀念，但我也喜欢这个。
You know, it's not either of them. You guys can go visit the set. We do. Exactly, anytime you want. But I am, you can't pull the wool over me. Why don't you not watch the studio? Yeah. Well you gotta really watch it.
你知道的，这不是二选一。你们随时可以去片场探班。我们会的。没错，随时欢迎。但我啊，你可蒙蔽不了我。你们为什么不看着制片厂呢？对。好吧，你真的得盯着点。
Like if you're not, we try to visit the set. If you don't visit, sometimes they think, oh, don't you care about us? But then when you do show up, people are worried, like, oh, are we over budget? Is there a problem? Really gotta navigate that carefully, of when and how we show up.
如果你不盯着，我们尽量去片场探班。如果你不去，有时他们会想，“哦，你们不关心我们吗？”但当你真的出现时，大家又会担心，“哦，我们是不是超预算了？是不是出什么问题了？”真的得小心翼翼地拿捏我们出现的时间和方式。
Who's more prone to say, hey, let's go visit that set? Who likes to get out a little bit more often? Oh, Pam, for sure. I like to go rogue. I have a terrible turbulence anxiety. Like, I have a flying phobia, so I do it, but it's not something that I volunteer for a lot. Yeah, Will has a little bit of that.
谁更容易说：嘿，我们去片场看看吧？谁更喜欢经常出去走走？哦，帕姆绝对是。我喜欢特立独行。我有严重的湍流焦虑。我有飞行恐惧症，所以我虽然会坐飞机，但这并不是我主动想去的地方。对，威尔也有点这毛病。
I do too, it's got increasingly worse. And you know what, in the last couple months it's been a little bit better, but these guys know I get quite, I don't know where. Will, you didn't have a bad experience, right? It's just like as you become older, you more respond to kids, right? When I had kids, when I had kids.
我也有，而且越来越严重了。你知道吗，过去几个月稍微好了一点，但这些家伙知道我经常会变得，我不知道该怎么说。威尔，你没经历过什么糟糕的事吧？这就像随着你年龄变大，你对孩子的反应更敏感了，对吧？当我有了孩子之后，当我有了孩子。
Same with you, Mike, or did you have a bad experience? Yeah, yeah, no bad experience. Shrink told me once, it's a control issue, obviously. A lot of people get it when they get their first dose of real responsibility. So when New Line made me head of production in the 90s, I was 26, 27, and it was the first big responsibility I ever got.
你也是这样吗，迈克，还是你经历过什么不好的事？对，对，没有不好的经历。心理医生曾经告诉我，这显然是一个控制问题。很多人在获得人生第一笔真正的责任时就会这样。所以当新线在90年代让我担任制作主管时，我才26、27岁，那是我得到的最大责任。
That's when I got the flying phobia, and then it's escalated since I've had children and gotten more responsibility. It just kind of increased exponentially. Have you thought about working, I have considered working through it, because I know I have a friend of mine who, years ago, and he had access to tremendous resources,
我就从那时候开始有了飞行恐惧症，自从我有了孩子、承担了更多责任之后，它就一直在升级。这种恐惧基本上呈指数级增长。你们有没有想过解决这个问题？我考虑过克服它，因为我知道我有个朋友，多年前，
but he went with that guy who's famous for walking people through that phobia, and he did, I think he told me he did a month of flights, and he'd go to like LaGuardia, he lives in New York, and they'd look at the board and they'd pick a flight and they'd fly to Cleveland, then they'd fly to Houston, then they'd fly to Miami, and he did that for about a month. And the guy walked him through basically every scenario.
他拥有极其丰富的资源，但他去找了那个以带人克服这种恐惧症而闻名的家伙，他真的去了，他告诉我他花了一个月时间坐飞机，他会去比如拉瓜迪亚机场——他住在纽约——然后他们看着航班时刻表挑一个航班飞往克利夫兰，接着飞休斯顿，然后飞迈阿密，他连续飞行了一个月。那个人带着他经历了基本上所有的场景。
And he got over it. Yeah, well I'm telling you, when I got stuck in that elevator, like my therapist said, the best thing you could do from now on, because then I was in such a massive panic, she goes, ride as many elevators as you possibly can. Right, it's like aversion therapy. It does help.
然后他克服了。对，我跟你说，当我有一次被困在电梯里时，我的治疗师说，从今以后你能做的最好的事——因为当时我陷入了极度恐慌——她说，尽可能多地去坐电梯。对，这就是暴露疗法。确实有用。
I accidentally stumbled into aversion therapy because my ex-wife lives in Fort Worth, Texas with my children and I travel there every weekend. So I'm on planes twice a week and it's just kind of normalized it for me. So that's helped a lot. And then information helps me. So I fly with a lot of apps.
我无意中接触到了暴露疗法，因为我的前妻和我的孩子们住在德克萨斯州沃斯堡，我每个周末都要飞过去。所以我一周坐两次飞机，这对我来说已经习以为常了。所以这帮了很大的忙。然后信息能给我安全感。所以我坐飞机时会用很多应用程序。
Like I have apps going that tell me where the plane is in relation to every other plane. Oh, you should fly with him. Me apps. Like I have apps going that tell me where the plane is in relation to every other plane. Oh you should fly with him. Me too. And what the weather is like. Wait a second. Mike, I'll tell you something. Mike, I do the same thing and I'll tell you
比如我开着各种软件，能告诉我这架飞机相对于其他每一架飞机的位置。哦，你应该跟他一起飞。我用应用。比如我开着各种软件，能告诉我这架飞机相对于其他每一架飞机的位置。哦，你应该跟他一起飞。我也是。还有天气怎么样。等一下。迈克，我跟你说件事。迈克，我也这么做，而且我告诉你
what I've done recently. Tracking traffic while you're in the air. Yeah, I track my own flight and I look at active weather and I look at flight aware and to see what the thing is and I'm like, are these guys gonna go around the storm or not? I'm right there with you brother. I literally will go to the flight attendant.
我最近都干了些什么。在空中时追踪航线。对，我追踪自己的航班，查看实时天气，查看 FlightAware，看看情况怎么样，然后我在想：这些家伙会绕过风暴还是直接冲过去？老弟，我和你完全一样。我真的会走到空乘人员面前。
Excuse me, flight attendant, I noticed that this plane at 34,000 feet is smooth because you perhaps ask our pilot to pick it up 2,000 feet because we're bopping around at 32. And she goes... By the way, do you know that they now have this new software that the pilots use that shows them where turbulence is, that they all share it and and it's like a,
打扰一下，空乘，我注意到这架飞机在34,000英尺的高度有点颠簸，你能请我们的飞行员把它拉高2,000英尺吗，因为我们在32,000英尺上下颠簸。然后她说……顺便说一句，你知道他们现在有一种飞行员使用的新软件，能显示气流颠簸在哪里，他们所有人都在共享这个信息，而且就像一个……
do you know about this? Yeah, pilot, yeah, pilot reporters. He knows everything, Will. He knows everything. I fly with him a lot. But here's my suggestion, and this is recent, just this spring, I decided to stop doing it. I had a moment, Mike, where I went,
你知道这个吗？对，飞行员，对，飞行员报告。他什么都知道，威尔。他什么都知道。我经常跟他一起飞。但我的建议是——这是最近的事，就在今年春天——我决定不再这么做了。有那么一刻，迈克，我心想：
I'm not flying this plane, and the pilots don't want to die. That's trust. Somehow you've achieved trust. I'm still working on trust. Here's what I do. I fly the first flight out as much as I can because I'm so unbelievably exhausted.
又不是我在开这架飞机，而且飞行员也不想死。这就是信任。不知怎的，你终于学会信任了。我还在努力培养信任。我是这么做的。我尽量赶最早的航班，因为我实在是累得精疲力竭。
I don't know what happens. Oh. Are you able to sleep on planes? I fall asleep in a second. Oh, I'm so envious of that. Well that explains your diet too, that you just, you don't care what happens. Mike, what about a nice, cool beverage
我也不知道为什么。哦。你在飞机上能睡着吗？我一秒钟就能睡着。哦，我太羡慕了。那这也解释了你的饮食习惯，你根本不在乎会发生什么。迈克，来一杯冰爽的饮料
to cut the edge or maybe a? You know, I'm sober, so I'm in a lifetime timeout of anything. What about, are sleeping pills on your list? No, I can't, yeah, they're on the no-fly list for me. What about melatonin? No? Yeah, I try to do it substance-free and just use my apps and engage with the flight attendants.
来放松一下，或者来点别的？你知道的，我已经戒酒了，所以我对任何这类东西都处在终身禁令中。安眠药在你的清单上吗？不，不行，对禁飞名单上对我来说是禁忌。那褪黑素呢？不？对，我尽量不使用任何药物，只靠我的应用程序和空乘人员交流。
Same. When we're flying together, I'll go check on him and then he tends to show me every app. So then I start to have a panic attack, which I don't normally have on a flight, but yes, that's what we do. Yeah, you know what I feel would help all of us is if we flew in one of those hurricane planes that the air hold has.
我也是。我们一起飞的时候，我会去看看他，然后他往往会向我展示所有的应用程序。接着我就开始恐慌发作了，这在坐飞机时我通常是不会的，但对，这就是我们常干的事。对，你知道我觉得能帮到我们所有人的是什么吗？如果我们能坐那种飓风猎人飞机去飞一次。
Totally, I think about that often. They fly literally into the wall of a hurricane to measure the speed of the winds. Well, that's just it. It turns out planes can handle so much more than you think that they can. So once you basically scuba dive with a shark, you're no longer scared of sharks
完全赞同，我经常这么想。他们竟然直接飞进飓风眼里去测量风速。就是这样。事实证明，飞机的承载能力远超你的想象。所以，一旦你和鲨鱼一起去水肺潜水，你就不再害怕鲨鱼了，
because you look them in the eye and they don't care about you. And by the way, I was talking to my therapist the other day and it turns out that humans can, we stand so much more too. Oh, Will. Jesus. Yeah, you can do it, Willie.
因为你直视它们的眼睛，而它们根本不在乎你。顺便说一句，我前几天跟我的治疗师聊天，结果发现人类也是这样，我们能承受得更多。哦，威尔。天哪。对，你能做到的，威利。
We are resilient. Humans can too. We can handle it. Now, let's talk about real fear. Let's talk about budgets. Let's talk about. Steve Zaz, let's talk about Zaz. Zaz locking on the door.
我们很有韧性。人类也可以。我们能挺过去。现在，我们来聊聊真正的恐惧。我们来聊聊预算。我们来聊聊……史蒂夫·扎兹（大卫·扎斯拉夫），我们来聊聊扎兹。扎兹在敲门了。
Also, but like to Jason's point though too, like I want to get into that because I'm fascinated watching from the sidelines about movies and stuff and like why, you know, what is your opinion about, because I'm sure you guys talk about this, we all talk about this, everybody in the business talks about what's the state of the business. Because it seems like, first of all,
不过，顺着杰森的观点来说，我也想深入探讨这个，因为作为一个在场外观察电影行业的人，我感到非常着迷。比如，你们怎么看——因为我确信你们讨论过这个，我们所有人都在讨论，行内每个人都在讨论行业的现状。因为看起来，首先，
it seems like you tell me the perception is that the star of any movie now is the idea, because movie stars, at least there are some that can still, you go, oh, I want to see that person, I like that person, I like that person. But for the most part, do I have that right? Or is that? Yeah, like stars used to open films,
似乎——你们告诉我，大家的普遍看法是，现在任何电影的明星都是“概念”本身，因为电影明星——至少还有一些人能让你觉得，哦，我想看那个人，我喜欢那个人，我喜欢那个人。但总的来说，我的理解对吗？还是说？对，以前明星能带火电影，
and now it's a little bit more plot and premise driven to drive audience. I think there's an element of truth to that. However, you see each new generation kind of wants, they still want to create their own movie stars. So you have people like Timothy Chalamet and Austin Butler.
现在则是更多靠剧情和前提来吸引观众。我觉得这里面确实有一定道理。然而，你发现每一代新人都在某种程度上渴望创造他们自己的电影明星。所以你有了蒂莫西·柴勒梅德和奥斯汀·巴特勒这样的人。
What a guy! And Florence Pugh. Basically, anyone on the red carpet for Barbie or Dune is an example of young audiences creating new movie stars. What brought audiences to that is the concept before the star, right? It's exponential.
真是个好样的！还有弗洛伦斯·皮尤。基本上，任何出现在《芭比》或《沙丘》红毯上的人，都是年轻观众打造新电影明星的例子。吸引观众走进影院的，是明星之前的那个概念，对吧？这是成倍增长的。
If you can, if you can, no, I think, I think Chalamet playing Bob Dylan was a great example. For sure. Combining, you know, something iconic with an actor people clearly want to see. I think there's opportunities to create new movie stars. Movie stars still matter, but it is, you know, with the advent of streaming,
如果你能，如果你能——不，我觉得，我觉得甜茶（柴勒梅德）扮演鲍勃·迪伦就是一个很好的例子。当然。将标志性的事物与观众明显想看的演员结合起来。我认为有机会创造新的电影明星。电影明星依然重要，但随着流媒体的兴起，
where people get so much content constantly, you do need that sticky idea and that provocative, audacious kind of concept to break through the action. With that pre-existing IP like Superman. Well, and we've been inundated, right? Who is it who said, Tom Rothman said, the tyranny of IP, and we've been inundated with it, right? And is there something?
人们不断接触到如此多的内容，你确实需要那个直击人心的点子和挑衅性、胆大包天的概念来打破重围。比如带有原有IP的超人。好吧，我们已经被淹没在IP中了，对吧？是谁说的来着？汤姆·罗斯曼说过，“IP的暴政”，我们被它淹没得透不过气，对吧？有没有什么？
Says the guy who only has one Marvel title. Yeah. Yeah. Way to go, way to go. Now you just made his shit list. Oh no, I loved him. No, no, no, no, I'm kidding, he's the great guy. And we will be right back.
这话居然出自一个只有一部漫威作品的家伙之口。对。太棒了，干得漂亮。现在你彻底上了他的黑名单了。哦不，我爱死他了。不，不，不，不，我开玩笑的，他是个大好人。我们马上回来。
And now back to the show. My question is, I guess, in the face of all of that, is there, and be as candid as you want to be, you're comfortable as being, given if all things being equal, if you could control the appetite of film goers and people who go into the theaters, what would be, what would you do? What kind of films would you make?
欢迎回到节目。我想我的问题是，面对这一切，是否存在着——请畅所欲言，怎么坦诚都行——如果在一切条件都平等的情况下，如果你能控制电影观众和走进影院的人的胃口，你会怎么做？你会拍什么样的电影？
Would you green light? Would you develop, you know, all things being equal? All things being equal, we really believe in a diversified slate because we feel like it's a, you know, the world's become pretty nichey. So we try to have something for everyone. So all your eggs aren't in one basket.
你会给什么开绿灯？在一切条件平等的情况下，你会开发什么？在一切条件平等的情况下，我们真的坚信应该保持多样化的电影排片，因为我们觉得世界已经变得非常小众了。所以我们尽量做到老少咸宜。这样你就不会把所有鸡蛋放在同一个篮子里。
You know, it's pretty, it's almost impossible, even for Disney, which owns those four giant labels of Lucasfilm and Pixar and Marvel, you can't have a 20 tent pole slate, just not that much IP available to just have nothing but billion dollar movies every year, although we certainly love it and everybody tries. But there's room for the originals too,
你知道的，这几乎是不可能的，即使对迪士尼来说——它拥有卢卡斯影业、皮克斯和漫威这四个巨无霸品牌——你也不可能每年推出20部大片构成的排片表，市面上根本没有那么多可用的IP来保证每年全是十亿美元级别的电影，虽然我们当然很喜欢，每个人也都想这么做。但原创电影同样有生存空间，
like what you guys did with Sinners, right? Yeah, we think a balanced slate, we have something for everyone, and yes, if you're lucky enough to have IP and you can mine those franchises, great, but then it's also great to give new voices a chance, new filmmakers, directors that want to do it. So if you could change one thing,
就像你们对《罪人》所做的那样，对吧？是的，我们认为排片应该平衡，要做到雅俗共赏。是的，如果你足够幸运拥有IP并能深耕这些系列，那很好；但同时，给新面孔、新电影人、想要尝试的导演一个机会，也是非常棒的。所以如果你能改变一件事，
you'd maybe try to get the audience to be a little bit more thirsty for something weird and original and without pre-existing. See, I think they are. But I think they are. Yeah, I think if we could change anything, it would be to get our fellow studios to make more movies. I think Box Office is down just because the amount of films has never really ticked back up since the pandemic started to resume.
你可能会试着让观众对那些古怪、原创且没有前作基础的东西产生更多的渴望。看，我觉得他们会的。但我觉得他们会的。对，如果我们能改变什么，那就是让同行为我们多拍几部电影。我觉得票房下滑只是因为自从疫情爆发以来，电影的数量就再也没有真正恢复到以前的水平。
Also you can just get it on streaming. Yeah. I mean the other thing I think that's important for the audience now is directors. I think there is a relationship with this next generation where they can tell when a signature filmmaker has their voice on a movie. They can tell that... Like a Jordan Peele or Ryan Coogler. Yeah, Jordan Peele or Ryan Coogler or Greta Gerwig or Chris Nolan.
而且你也可以直接在流媒体上看。对。我的意思是，我觉得现在对观众来说同样重要的是导演。我觉得他们与下一代人有一种联系，当一个具有标志性风格的电影人在一部电影中展现出他的声音时，他们是能感觉得出来的。他们能看出来……就像乔丹·皮尔或瑞恩·库格勒。对，乔丹·皮尔、瑞恩·库格勒、格蕾塔·葛韦格或克里斯·诺兰。
Paul Thomas Anderson. They can sense authorship or the lack of it. They really can. Jason Bateman. Jason Bateman. What? Absolutely Jason Bateman. We're waiting for a much bigger filmography, man.
保罗·托马斯·安德森。他们能感觉到作者风格，或者缺乏这种风格。他们真的能。杰森·贝特曼。杰森·贝特曼。什么？绝对是杰森·贝特曼。我们还在等你的作品列表再丰富一点呢，老兄。
Jason Bateman picture. He refers himself to the third person a lot. I think the world needs another Jason Bateman picture. I told him. I love Jason. I told you. I told Jason to start directing when we were making Identity C. He's such a good director and we always encourage him to make more comedies too because he's such a funny little foe. But can I ask you this though, just while we're on this topic, is there, and again, at the risk of,
杰森·贝特曼的电影。他经常用第三人称来称呼自己。我觉得世界需要另一部杰森·贝特曼的电影。我跟他说了。我爱杰森。我告诉过你的。我在拍《身份窃贼》的时候就叫杰森开始当导演了。他是个这么优秀的导演，我们总是鼓励他多拍点喜剧，因为他是个那么搞笑的小家伙。不过我能问你们个问题吗，就在我们讨论这个话题的时候，有没有——冒着
I don't want to hurt anybody's feelings, but has the sort of the onslaught of IP, and again, there are lots of great films that have come out in this era, and there are a lot of people whom we all know and love who have made these and have done really well, and blah, blah, blah, the list is very long. But have we, in a certain way,
不想伤害任何人感情的风险——海量的IP轰炸——当然，这个时代诞生了很多伟大的电影，而且有许多我们熟知并热爱的人制作了这些作品并且取得了巨大成功，等等等等，这个名单非常长。但是我们，在某种程度上，
have we dulled our taste buds for other kinds of films? Have we changed, is there a chance that we altered people's tastes a little too much? Because the big things are so loud and sticky now? Well, yeah, that we don't, you know, we were all, we're all older, we're all the same sort of generation. We were all raised on a diversified slate of films that came out every year, and there were lots of comedies
我们是不是已经对其他类型的电影变得迟钝了？我们是不是改变了，有没有可能我们把人们的口味稍微改变得有点过头了？因为现在的大片声势太浩大、太黏人了？嗯，是的，我们不再，你知道的，我们都老了，我们都是同一代人。我们都是看着每年上映的各种类型的电影长大的，当时有大量的喜剧、
and dramas and action, et cetera, et cetera. And so we- You had the verdict in Raging Bull and Kramer versus Kramer, which now you can't have those sort of adult dramas. And so now everything's been kind of, it's kind of like, you know, it's what people complain about pop music, if you will,
剧情片和动作片等等等等。所以我们——你们有《大审判》、《愤怒的公牛》和《克莱默夫妇》，而现在你们拍不出那种成人剧情片了。所以现在一切都被格式化了，有点像——你知道的，这就是人们抱怨流行音乐时所说的那样，
that everything just becomes the very, you know, homogenized and very much the same. And have we damaged tastes? I don't think so, I think. And again, because the tastes are always refreshed by new audiences coming up. I think what's happened is the bar has just gotten higher for what we consider theater-worthy criteria,
一切都变得非常同质化，千篇一律。我们的口味被毁了吗？我不觉得，我觉得。而且话说回来，口味总是会被不断涌现的新观众所刷新。我觉得发生的变化是，对于我们认为符合“大银幕标准”的东西——也就是能让它不上流媒体、而是在影院上映的标准——门槛变高了。
things that will make something not streaming, but theatrical. But I think when you see a spread of theatrical successes from Long Legs or everything, every all at once from the Neons and the H24s, they're not tent poles, they're not making a billion dollars globally, but they are pulling in audiences theatrically.
但我觉得当你看到影院成功的影片分布时，从《长腿》到 Neon 和 A24 的《瞬息全宇宙》，它们不是超级大片，全球票房没有达到十亿美元，但它们确实把观众吸引进了电影院。
And then on our side of the street, when you have something as diverse as Minecraft, and then the next weekend, sinners are at Universal, Oppenheimer, and then we had Barbie, I think that people are up for the theatrical experience, and they're up for a variety of movies. The bar is just higher for what, we'll get them out of the house and that's our job to meet that higher
然后在我们的地盘上，当你有像《我的世界》这样风格迥异的作品，紧接着下一个周末是环球影业的《罪人》、奥本海默，然后我们推出了《芭比》，我觉得人们已经准备好享受影院体验了，他们也准备好接受各种各样的电影了。门槛变高了，我们要把他们吸引出家门，而达到这个更高的门槛就是我们的工作。
bar. And it's less about how theatrical is not as good, it is more about how streaming is more appealing and there's good stuff to watch at home and so... And convenient. Yeah, they're not mutually exclusive. There's enough to go around. Yeah, I think there are consumers that are happy to wait for streaming or watch streaming originals
这与其说是因为影院体验变差了，不如说是因为流媒体更有吸引力了，家里有好看的东西可看，所以……而且很方便。对，这两者并不排斥。好东西多得是。对，我觉得有些观众乐意等待流媒体上线，或者观看流媒体原创内容，
and then there's consumers that want the theatrical experience. Yeah, and there are people who don't want to ever leave their house, right? Who don't want to go, they won't even go to Larchmont, even though it's three blocks away. Right. I wonder who that could be. Yeah, you can get everything on your phone. Go ahead, Sean.
然后也有那些想要影院体验的观众。对，还有人根本不想离开家，对吧？他们根本不想出门，甚至连 Larchmont 大街都不愿意去，尽管它离他们只有三个街区远。对，我很好奇那个人会是谁。对，你在手机上就能搞定一切。请继续，肖恩。
Now, but you said you'd love it if studios made more movies. What do you think is the primary reason that they're not making more movies because it's getting increasingly more expensive to build a sort of a public profile for it, like a marketing profile, like you got to have, you got to buy a bunch of commercials for it and sort of build that social pressure to go see this thing because everyone's seeing the billboards and the commercials and oh my god I guess I got to go see that because I got to talk about it at work. It's cost so much money to buy those commercials and those billboards that people say, ah maybe
现在，但是你刚才说过，如果电影公司能拍更多电影你会觉得很高兴。你觉得他们没有拍更多电影的主要原因是什么？是不是因为为电影建立某种公众形象（比如营销形象）的成本越来越高了？比如你得为它买一堆广告，还得制造那种去看这部电影的社会压力，因为每个人都看到了广告牌和广告，然后“天哪，我想我得去看看，因为我得在工作时跟别人聊这个”。买这些广告和广告牌要花太多钱，以至于人们会说：“啊，也许……”
I'll just make it for streaming where I don't need to do all that stuff. It's just production costs. Is that one of the big things that? No, I think it's about, yes, it's expensive to make some films, but you can make films at different budget levels, depending on what it is. But isn't the price to sell them the same? But I think you have to meet,
“我还是直接把它放到流媒体上拍吧，我就不需要搞那些乱七八糟的东西了。”这只是制作成本的问题吗？这是主要原因之一吗？不，我觉得这是关于……是的，拍某些电影确实很贵，但你可以根据电影的内容，在不同的预算水平下拍电影。但卖电影的成本不是一样的吗？但我觉得你必须迎合……
I think marketing has changed, and I think you have to meet the audience where they're receiving their advertising. Not necessarily a 30. Not necessarily a 30 second linear TV spot, but digitally. What we saw, just how we saw the fervor of Minecraft with the chicken jockey and the memes taking on a life of its own coupled with two weeks later Sinners
我觉得营销方式已经变了，而且我觉得你必须在受众接收广告的地方迎合他们。不一定非得是30秒的传统电视广告，而是数字化的。我们所看到的，就像我们看到《我的世界》狂热现象一样，里面有鸡骑士和那些具有独立生命的表情包，再加上两周后的《罪人》……
and Mike and my TikTok feed just filling with people, experiencing this film, like that was magical, like magical to see that happen. And I think that's where they are. I think every legacy studio, by legacy studio, I mean, the Paramount, Sony, us, the non-streamers, coming out of the pandemic, everyone is cautious about, okay, is box office down
还有Mike和我的TikTok动态里到处都是人们体验这部电影的场景，那简直太神奇了，看到这一幕发生太神奇了。我觉得这正是他们的现状。我觉得每一家传统电影公司——我说的传统电影公司，是指派拉蒙、索尼、我们这些非流媒体公司——在疫情过后，每个人都在谨慎对待：好吧，票房下降是因为……
because the pandemic irrevocably altered viewing habits? Or is box office down because we're making less movies? You know, Pam and I feel like it's because we're making less movies. Some people feel human behavior may have been altered and the audience may be never coming back at the level they were in pre-pandemic. So I think as everybody tries to figure out the answer
是因为疫情彻底改变了人们的观影习惯？还是因为我们拍的电影变少了？你知道，帕姆和我觉得是因为我们拍的电影变少了。有些人觉得人类的行为可能已经改变了，观众可能再也不会回到疫情前的水平了。所以我觉得当大家都在试图找出这个问题的答案时……
to that, and it's a very fluid situation, working your slate back up to 10, 15, 20 movies a year, I just, it's going to be a slow, cautious process. Everyone's kind of feeling their way of, what's exactly causing the downturn? Is it the hangover from the pandemic, or is it that we're not making the same amount of movies?
这是一个非常多变的情况，要把你的电影片单恢复到每年10部、15部、20部，我只是觉得，这是一个缓慢而谨慎的过程。每个人都在摸索，到底是什么导致了市道低迷？是疫情带来的后遗症，还是我们拍的电影数量不如从前了？
Right, almost to that point, it seems like, and you guys tell me, more people than ever are out of work in the history of the entertainment business. It seems like writers that used to work all the time can't find a gig, like more actors, directors, producers, crew, everybody. Why is that in your opinion,
没错，说到这里，似乎——你们也说说看——娱乐行业失业的人数比历史上任何时候都要多。似乎那些过去经常有活儿干的编剧找不到工作了，更多的演员、导演、制片人、剧组人员，所有人都是如此。在你看来，为什么会这样？
and what does your crystal ball say about the future of that? Do you see that changing? Like Village Roadshow, didn't they just go bankrupt or something? It just seems like the entertainment business is collapsing. It's constrict. Yeah, it's getting smaller because there's less stuff being made, yeah?
你对这方面的未来有什么预测？你觉得这种情况会改变吗？就像威レRoadshow（Village Roadshow），他们不是刚申请破产还是怎么的？感觉娱乐行业正在崩溃。它在收缩。是的，它在变小，因为拍的东西变少了，对吧？
Yeah, there's work, but there's been some consolidation in the industry, so that immediately means less buyers on the block. Yeah, there's been some consolidation in the industry so that immediately means less buyers on the block. There was a contraction in production, both on the series side and the feature side as we were navigating the pandemic and then the so-called streaming wars, which were never really a war. Netflix won that war before it even started. Right, right, right. They had a 20-year head start. I do think things are picking up and will tick up.
是的，工作机会还在，但行业内进行了一些整合，这直接意味着市场上的买家减少了。是的，行业内进行了一些整合，这直接意味着市场上的买家减少了。制作规模有所收缩，无论是在剧集方面还是在电影方面，因为我们当时正在经历疫情，然后是所谓的流媒体大战，虽然那从来都不是真正的战争。Netflix在战争开始之前就已经赢了。对，对，对。他们有20年的领先优势。我确实认为情况正在好转，并且将会回暖。
Maybe not to pre-pandemic levels, but I think that has been a symptom of both. It's all cyclical, right? Yes. Yeah, I was just going to say, the studio's making less movies, like we were saying, but also if you go to TV, streaming has created the eight to 10 episode series
也许不会恢复到疫情前的水平，但我认为这是这两者共同作用的症状。这一切都是周期性的，对吧？是的。是的，我正想说，电影公司拍的电影变少了，就像我们刚才说的，但如果你看看电视剧，流媒体创造了8到10集的剧集……
as opposed to what we all grew up with on network television with 22 episodes. And you constantly felt like you had all those linear networks that were creating multiple shows filling must-see TV and all that stuff. And I feel like that has been altered quite a bit since the streaming and since the pandemic. Right.
而不是我们小时候在电视网看到的22集的电视剧。你会觉得有那么多传统电视网在制作多部剧集，填满“必看电视”之类的节目。我觉得自从有了流媒体和疫情之后，这一切都发生了很大的改变。没错。
Sean used to do, how many, 24 episodes a year on Will and Grace? Sometimes 22, sometimes 26, sometimes 24. Yeah, it was crazy. Amazing. And then they don't, oh, Zark, how many do you guys do? Just 10. JB, 10?
肖恩以前拍过，在《威尔和格蕾丝》里一年拍多少集？有时22集，有时26集，有时24集。是的，太疯狂了。太惊人了。然后他们不……哦，扎克，你们拍多少集？只有10集。JB，10集？
10. And they're remaking it, right? They're doing it with robots and they said it's got more life to it. You see the way he can set it and hit it. It's good. Yeah, it breathes more. Yeah, but, shoot, what was I going to say?
10集。他们要在翻拍，对吧？他们用机器人来拍，而且他们说这更有活力。你看他那种运镜和踩点的方式。挺好的。对，更有呼吸感。对，但是，该死，我刚要说什么来着？
By the way, we use Lego Batman in every tribute reel to Warner. Every Best of Warner Brothers reel that we screen at CinemaCon, we always include Lego Batman. Don't do that to him, Mike. He's kind of dying out on that. Thank you. Yeah, it's our favorite. Don't do that to him, Mike. He's kind of dying out on that. Thank you. We love it. So guys, you have been uniquely great individually
顺便说一句，我们在华纳的每一个致敬短片里都用了乐高蝙蝠侠。我们在CinemaCon上播放的每一个“华纳兄弟最佳”短片里，我们总是会把乐高蝙蝠侠包含进去。别对他这样，迈克。他在这方面快说不出话了。谢谢。是的，这是我们的最爱。别对他这样，迈克。他在这方面快说不出话了。谢谢。我们太喜欢了。所以各位，你们在个人方面都非常出色……
and also together in really getting behind some of the more specific creative voices behind these movies. People like Paul Thomas Anderson and David Fincher, et cetera, et cetera. When you are collaborating with someone like that who they like to keep the edges on and that's what the audience likes too,
而且在真正支持这些电影背后一些更具特色的创作声音方面也非常默契。像保罗·托马斯·安德森和大卫·芬奇等人。当你与这样的人合作时，他们喜欢保持棱角，这也是观众所喜欢的……
but sometimes, oftentimes, that's at odds with the goal to get as many people into the tent as possible, buying a ticket and making it mass appeal and kind of round the edges sometimes and not be as controversial, not be as challenging. How do you manage that? On the producing side, on the selling side, it's probably a lot easier, but in your current roles
但有时，通常情况下，这与让尽可能多的人走进影院、买票、实现大众化吸引力、磨平棱角、不那么具有争议性、不那么具有挑战性的目标相悖。你们是如何处理这一点的？在制作端、在销售端，这可能容易得多，但在你们目前的职责中……
as trying to bring in profits as well, are those conversations difficult? Do you err on one side or the other? Walk us through that a little bit. I find it because of our background. I mean, listen, I'm 30 years in. Mike's longer than that. We're just a little. It's very polite of you, Pam.
既要带来利润，这些对话困难吗？你们会偏向哪一边吗？给我们稍微讲讲这个过程。我觉得，因为我们的背景。听我说，我已经干了30年了。迈克干的时间比这还长。我们只是稍微……帕姆，你太客气了。
Thank you for saying that. Wow. Not naming the number of years. I mean, the shot's fired. No, no, no. I'm just saying, I'm 30 years in, whatever. But I think because both he and I have been in the trenches on a producerial side, there's a certain level
谢谢你这么说。哇。没有说出具体年限。我的意思是，这简直是神仙过招。不，不，不。我的意思是，我干了30年了，不管怎样。但我认为，因为我和他在制片端都曾在基层摸爬滚打过……
of understanding and trust that we bring to this job. So the filmmakers that we work with, some of them we've had long relationships, like we're working with Alejandro and Uriichu right now, I'm on my fourth film with him. I think there's a trust, there's a collaboration, there's a respect. I mean, you have to earn the filmmaker's respect, you know?
我们在这份工作中带来了一种程度的理解和信任。所以我们合作的电影人，有些我们已经建立了长期的合作关系，比如我们现在正跟亚历杭德罗合作，这是我跟他合作的第四部电影。我认为这里面有信任、有合作、有尊重。我的意思是，你必须赢得电影人的尊重，你知道吗？
So I think what we bring to the table is because we have this knowledge of being on the ground and going through the ups and downs and the difficulties of what it is to be on set every day and try to make something great because we all set out to make something great and sometimes shit happens and it doesn't come out exactly how you envisioned it,
所以我觉得我们带到谈判桌上的东西，是因为我们有在基层摸爬滚打、经历起伏的经验，知道每天在片场努力创作出优秀作品的艰难，因为我们所有人的目标都是创作出伟大的作品，有时候操蛋的事情发生了，结果并没有完全如你所愿……
you have to be in lockstep together as creative partners. So I think Mike and I try to approach it that way where we look at filmmakers as our partners. We all have the same end goal, to make something great and to get the biggest audience in the theater to see it. So I don't find it difficult. I actually find it invigorating. Well, that's really funny, Pam.
你们必须作为创意伙伴保持高度一致。所以我觉得我和迈克试图以这种方式来处理它，我们将电影人视为我们的伙伴。我们都有相同的最终目标：创作出伟大的作品，并吸引最多的观众进影院观看。所以我觉得这并不困难。我甚至觉得这很振奋人心。嗯，这真的很有趣，帕姆。
That's really funny because you often hear people, you do in comments and stuff saying, these violent people in Hollywood and they just want to make shit movies like, nobody sets out to make a shitty movie, by the way. Everybody's intentions are good. Right. Right.
这真的很有趣，因为你经常听到人们在评论区之类的地方说：“好莱坞这些暴戾的人只想拍烂片。”顺便说一句，没有人是为了拍烂片而出发的。大家的初衷都是好的。对的。对的。
And there's no blanket statement for Hollywood. Like it's so, it's so different. You know, our friend Donna Langley at Universal is different than Tom Rothman at Sony. We do our thing at Warner's. Like it's not- Donna, another one from New Line that started out. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
而且对于好莱坞不能一概而论。它太……太不一样了。你知道，我们在环球影业的朋友唐娜·兰利和索尼的汤姆·罗特曼就不一样。我们在华纳有我们自己的风格。这并不是——唐娜，也是从新线电影公司出来的另一位。对，对，完全是。
Not as an intern, right? No, we actually hired Dona, she was an assistant to a manager at the time. Wow. And she and another executive, Mary Parent, who went on to do great things and is running legendary for Josh Grode. It's a factory.
不是从实习生开始的吧？不，其实是我们雇佣了唐娜，她当时是一个经纪人的助理。哇。她和另一位高管玛丽·帕伦特一起，后者后来取得了巨大的成就，现在为乔什·格罗德管理传奇影业。这是一个造星工厂。
New Line, it was a great kind of training ground for a lot of people in the 90s. And you met Donna and you knew she was going to run an empire someday. I mean, she was just born to do it. And has been in that position of leadership longer than anyone? Yeah.
新线，在90年代是培养很多人的一个绝佳训练场。你遇到了唐娜，你就知道她总有一天会管理一个帝国。我的意思是，她生来就是干这个的。而且担任领导岗位的时间比任何人都长？对。
Like ever maybe? Through multiple regimes. Running universal? It's just so awesome. The people who have come in and out of New Line, it's a pretty interesting slate of people now that I think about it. All the people, Brenner's still there with you, right? Yeah, he is.
可能是有史以来最长？经历了多个管理层。管理环球影业？真是太棒了。现在想来，那些进出过新线的人，现在的阵容相当有趣。所有那些人，布伦纳现在还在你们那里，对吧？对，他在。
Then you've got- Toby Emrick, wasn't he? No, obviously Toby. And then you have our buddy Ken Alterman, who was there, who we're still, Jason and I still play golf with. We love Ken Alterman. That's cool.
然后你们还有——托比·艾默里奇，他不是吗？不，当然是托比。然后你们还有我们的老朋友肯·奥尔特曼，他以前也在那儿，我们现在——杰森和我现在还跟他一起打高尔夫球。我们很喜欢肯·奥尔特曼。这太酷了。
Love, love Ken. And I'm just thinking like, wow, that was it. What an interesting place that was for a lot of people who kind of, you know, learned their stuff there. Yeah, we were given the freedom to really run our projects and even though you're an executive, you almost behave like a producer at New Line at that time. So we all learned a lot.
非常喜欢肯。我就在想，哇，就是这样。对于很多在那里学到真本事的人来说，那是一个多么有趣的地方啊。是的，我们被赋予了真正的自由来运作我们的项目，尽管你是一名高管，但在当时的新线，你的行为举止几乎就像一个制片人。所以我们都学到了很多。
Interesting. And it really does seem like you guys are creating that or continuing that environment of trust and deference to a very specific filmmaker agenda, like something like Sinners, for example. I have not seen it yet, but from what I've seen from the materials and heard from people, it's a very specific and exciting creative leap.
有趣。而且你们似乎确实在创造或延续那种信任的环境，并且对非常具体的电影人议程保持尊重，比如《罪人》这部电影。我还没看过，但从我看到的素材和听到大家说的来看，这是一次非常具体且令人兴奋的创意飞跃。
Oh yeah, it's been amazing for it. We're so happy for Ryan. Selling popcorn and getting incredible reviews. So that's the mother load right there, right? So talk about how frightening that can be to, while you, as you say, Pam, you're a partner with the filmmaker, you're coming from a place of shared experience,
哦，是的，这对它来说太棒了。我们为瑞安感到高兴。卖爆米花而且收获了难以置信的评价。所以这才是王牌，对吧？那么，谈谈这会有多可怕：虽然正如你所说，帕姆，你和电影人是伙伴，你们有着共同的经历……
and you kind of know what they're going through, and blah, blah, blah, but eventually one has to just kind of close your eyes and jump in and just say, all right, Ryan, I get what you're going for here. We're really not gonna be able to gauge until we're done. And so we have to trust you. We have to wait till after principal photography,
你差不多知道他们在经历什么，等等等等，但最终你只能闭上眼睛跳下去，然后说：“好吧，瑞安，我明白你想达到什么效果了。在我们完成之前，我们真的无法评估。所以我们必须信任你。我们必须等到主体拍摄结束……”
get through post, have all that music come in and the color timing and all that stuff to create this very finely cooked meal that it looks like nothing coming out of the grocery store. You look at all the ingredients on it, like you don't know what you've got till it's cooked. And so you have to give him all of that runway. Is that really, really frightening
完成后期制作，加入所有的音乐、色彩分级等等，来创造出这顿精心烹制的美味，它看起来一点也不像从杂货店里拿出来的东西。你看上面的所有配料，在它煮好之前你根本不知道自己做出了什么。所以你必须给他所有的创作空间。这真的……真的很可怕吗？
or is it exciting or both? And we'll be right back. All right. Sorry, we got to reload. No, it is a good question. It is a good question. It was long, but it is a good question. I find it exciting, I have to be honest.
还是说这很令人兴奋，或者两者兼有？我们马上回来。好的。抱歉，我们得重新加载。不，这是一个好问题。这是一个好问题。虽然有点长，但确实是个好问题。说实话，我觉得这很令人兴奋。
I think when you have that chemistry with a filmmaker, with a director, and when you're pushing and pulling on things, it's not like we're just sitting here saying, hey, go off and run in the field and make this movie. We're all talking all the time through the script process, through the screening process. Run in the field, where'd you get that from? Because I don't know, it's just, you know.
我觉得当你和一位电影人、一位导演有这种化学反应，当你们在各个事情上互相推拉时，这并不意味着我们只是坐在那里说：“嘿，去田野里奔跑，把这部电影拍出来吧。”我们在整个剧本创作过程、试映过程中一直在沟通。“在田野里奔跑”，你从哪学来的这个？因为我不知道，这只是……
Run and kill. Go off and play it, and play, and play. This is going to be a new, people are going to start to use this, by the field. Where'd you get that from? Because I don't know. It's just, you know, go off and play it and play and play. People are going to start to use this, by the way. Thanks, Will. Thanks for Mike teasing me. Thanks, Will. Netflix meeting tomorrow, they're going to be like, look, guys, we're not going to be running in the field over here.
去奔跑和消灭。去玩吧，去玩，去玩。顺便说一句，这会成为一个新梗，人们要开始用这个了，“在田野里”。你从哪学来的？因为我不知道。这只是，你知道的，去玩吧，去玩，去玩。顺便说一句，人们要开始用这个了。谢谢，威利。谢谢迈克取笑我。谢谢，威利。明天开Netflix会议时，他们会说：“听着，各位，我们可不打算在这里去田野里奔跑。”
That's how Jason's going to... That's how Jason's going to... Exactly. You're going to sell your next movie. I just want to run in the field. Frolicking, you know, having a good time. It's going to be the variety headline tomorrow, like Pam Abbey of Warner Bros. advocates field running as a business plan. By the way, the last six weeks I've been having, I wouldn't be surprised.
杰森就会这样……杰森就会这样……没错。你下一部电影就是这么卖出去的。我只是想在田野里奔跑。嬉戏打闹，你知道的，度过一段美好的时光。明天《综艺》杂志的头条就会写着：华纳兄弟的帕姆·艾比提倡将“田野奔跑”作为商业计划。顺便说一句，过去六周我一直在经历这些，我也不会感到惊讶。
Anyway. Warner Bros. Warner Ankle's field running. Anyway. No, no, no, no. Warner Brothers, Warner Ankle's field running. Or Ankle's. But you know, Ryan, when you're dealing with, like Ryan comes to the table trailing, you know, like two billion in box office.
不管怎样。华纳兄弟。华纳安克的田野奔跑。不管怎样。不，不，不，不。华纳兄弟，华纳安克的田野奔跑。或者安克。但你知道，瑞安，当你打交道时，比如瑞安带着两0亿票房的光环来到谈判桌前……
Like he, yes, you could call it IP, but he created the Creed franchise out of his head. Right, yeah. And he, Black Panther, you know, I'm a comic book fan. I'm a huge comic book collector still and geek fan. And I knew the Black Panther character, but it's not like that was one of the top 10 characters. Ryan, you know, created that franchise also,
就像他，是的，你可以称之为IP，但他凭空创造了《奎迪》系列。对，是的。还有，他拍了《黑豹》，你知道的，我是个漫画迷。我至今仍然是一个狂热的漫画收藏家和极客粉丝。我知道黑豹这个角色，但它并不是那种前十名的角色。瑞安，你知道的，他也创造了这个系列……
again, out of his mind, obviously under the brilliant Kevin Feige too. But so when you're doing a film with Ryan Coogler, who has that pedigree, it is a little bit of a hedge against the unknown. I mean, greenlining movies at a studio is like being at a casino. You have a certain amount of money
当然，这也是在他的脑海中构思出来的，显然在伟大的凯文·费奇的指导下也是如此。所以当你和拥有这种资历的瑞安·库格勒合作一部电影时，这在一定程度上是对未知的对冲。我的意思是，在电影公司给电影亮绿灯就像在赌场里一样。你手里有一笔资金……
and you're placing bets and you're hoping more than work than don't work. But the only hedge against the unknown is sometimes you can point to someone's track record. You know, like when we hired David Fincher to do Seven, you know, I thought Alien 3 was a beautiful movie. It didn't work as big as they wanted to commercially, but there was tremendous artistry,
你在下注，并且希望成功的比失败的多。但对冲未知风险的唯一方法有时就是参考某人的过往战绩。你知道的，就像我们雇佣大卫·芬奇拍《七宗罪》时，我觉得《异形3》是一部美丽的电影。它在商业上没有达到他们想要的规模，但其中体现了巨大的艺术性……
and of course he had all his music videos and his commercials before that point, made hiring him for Seven very, very easy. We were lucky to have him. So when you can look at someone's pedigree, whether they're established like Ryan or a new voice coming up, like we just made a movie with this guy,
当然，在此之前他拍过所有的音乐录影带和广告，这使得雇佣他来拍《七宗罪》变得非常非常容易。我们很幸运能拥有他。所以，当你可以参考某人的资历时，无论他是像瑞安那样成名已久的新星，还是崭露头角的新声音——比如我们刚刚和这家伙合作了一部电影……
Zach Craigor, who did the movie Barbarian, and I think he's an amazing. I love that movie. Wasn't that an amazing movie? Yeah, it's so good. Totally unique, surprising in the genre, innovated within the genre. You know, we were lucky to get his next movie.
扎克·克雷格，他拍了电影《野蛮人》，我觉得他是一个了不起的……我喜欢那部电影。那难道不是一部惊艳的电影吗？对，太棒了。完全独特，在这个类型片中充满了惊喜，并在类型中进行了创新。你知道，能拍到他的下一部电影我们很幸运。
When you can look at someone's previous work, also another great horror movie that came out, Talk to Me, you know, by these two directors who started on a YouTube channel, Rocka Rocka in Australia. When you can look at people's previous work, it gives you a little bit of a hedge against the unknown and that helps us make that call sometimes.
当你看到某人以前的作品时，还有另一部上映的伟大恐怖片《索命l》，你知道的，这两位导演是从澳大利亚的YouTube频道“洛卡洛卡”起步的。当你能看到人们以前的作品时，这会在一定程度上帮你对冲未知风险，有时这能帮助我们做出决定。
There used to be that old adage, or that thing that people would say, that the studios are in the business of not making movies, right? Do you remember now, is that true? Yeah, I remember that, I remember thing that people would say that the studios are in the business of not making movies, right? Do you remember now, is that true? Yeah, I remember that. I remember when they used to say that. There was a period, right?
过去流传着这样一句老话，或者人们常说的话，那就是电影公司是靠“不拍电影”来赚钱的，对吧？你还记得吗？现在是这样吗？是的，我记得，我记得人们过去常说电影公司是靠不拍电影赚钱的，对吧？你还记得吗？现在是这样吗？是的，我记得。我记得他们过去这么说的时候。曾几何时，对吧？
Studios were playing defense. Well, there was a period when I was a non-writing producer, which is literally like Willy Loman with scripts under your arm, like driving all over town, you know, pitching your wares. That was just from somebody who just got, you get somebody passed on. They're like, yeah, studios are making movies.
电影公司当时在打防守战。嗯，曾经有一段时间，我是一个非编剧制片人，这简直就像是威利·罗曼手里夹着剧本，开车满城跑去推销你的商品。那只是来自某个被拒绝的人。他们会说：“对啊，电影公司在拍电影。”
Studios would almost be like, we dare you to make a movie. We dare you to get us to make a movie. And that I find not a helpful attitude. Yeah, that's not helpful. I also don't think you can declare, I think that was like in the early 2000s, Will, when people were like after the boom of the 90s and like where starting to shift
电影公司几乎会表现得像是在说：“有本事你让我们拍部电影啊。”“有本事你让我们拍部电影啊。”我觉得这种态度一点也不好。是的，这毫无帮助。而且我也不认为你可以断言——我觉得那大约是在20世纪20年代初，威利，当时人们在经历90年代的繁荣之后，情况开始转变……
and internet and all that stuff was happening in tech and everything. I just don't think you can declare any one thing, right? You can't say this is the way it is so we shouldn't make these kinds of movies until one works. Although when we lost DVDs, when DVDs went away, we did lose a safety net.
互联网和所有那些科技相关的事情正在发生。我只是觉得你不能单方面宣称某种东西，对吧？你不能说事情就是这样，所以我们不应该拍这种电影，直到有一部成功了。尽管当我们失去了DVD时，DVD消失时，我们确实失去了一个安全网。
And streaming doesn't quite make up that gap. So we are lose a safety net. We are working without a net, but I also think, like Pam said, that can be really exciting. I think for the consumer, it means that the bar for quality really, really has to be high to get you to get out of your house and convert to being a ticket buyer. But people couldn't have predicted back then in the early 2000 what it was gonna become. And I think that that sort of fear, so as you said, you lost DVDs. However, everybody was so nervous at the advent of the internet and social media.
而流媒体并没有完全弥补这个缺口。所以我们失去了安全网。我们在没有安全网的情况下运作，但我也觉得，正如帕姆所说，这真的很令人兴奋。我认为对于消费者来说，这意味着质量门槛必须非常非常高，才能让你走出家门，转化成购票观众。但当年20世纪初的人们根本无法预测未来会变成什么样。我认为这种恐惧……正如你所说，你们失去了DVD。然而，当互联网和社交媒体出现时，每个人都感到非常紧张。
You remember the fear, I remember the first, when MySpace took off and people were trying to green light movies with people who had a presence on MySpace and everybody's clamoring. People were not able to predict what it would be in the same way that we can't now with things like AI, et cetera. And of course we're gonna look back in 10 years and say,
你还记得那种恐惧吗？我记得第一次，当MySpace崛起时，人们试图给那些在MySpace上有存在感的人的项目亮绿灯，每个人都在争先恐后。人们无法预测它会变成什么样，就像我们现在对人工智能等技术无法预测一样。当然，我们在10年后回首会说：
my God, we were so foolish to spend so much time worried about X, Y and Z. I agree. Yeah, totally. Because obviously something else will happen. People will want to watch stuff. People will want to enjoy stuff in some way And there is the community they want the communal experience, you know first certain kinds of films They want to go and sit with their neighbors and go watch the movie and then go to a cafe afterwards or a bar
天哪，我们当初怎么会这么傻，花那么多时间去担心X、Y、Z。我同意。是的，完全同意。因为显然会有别的事情发生。人们会想要看东西。人们会想以某种方式享受乐趣，而且这里存在社区感——他们想要那种集体的体验，你知道的，对于某种特定类型的电影，他们想去看，和邻居坐在一起看电影，然后去咖啡馆或酒吧……
And have a drink and talk about it Yeah, and I get that being in a being, a big dark room with a bunch of strangers, it's really fun to like get a shared experience. My 20s, those were my 20s in Chicago. Yes. That was Berlin for me, that's Berlin. Twice a year, I allow myself, twice a year. We'll be right back.
喝一杯，聊一聊。是的，我懂那种感觉，在一个黑暗的大房间里和一群陌生人在一起，获得一种共同的体验真的很有趣。我二十多岁的时候，那是我在芝加哥的二十多岁。是的。对我来说那是柏林，那是柏林。一年两次，我允许自己，一年两次。我们马上回来。
And back to the show. But to like everybody be in the same room and back to the show. But to like everybody be in the same room all at the same time get scared, I get why horror movies make so much money. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Now to think about crying next to a stranger, I get how maybe dramas, I'd rather maybe see that at home on a streamer,
欢迎回到节目。但就像大家同时呆在同一个房间里感到害怕一样，我能理解为什么恐怖电影能赚这么多钱。是的，是的，肯定的。现在想想在一个陌生人旁边哭泣，我能理解为什么有些剧情片，我宁愿在家里通过流媒体看……
I get that. What I don't get is that there isn't the desire for shared experience with laughter in a group of people. So tell us what you guys think, what is your theory of why comedy is such a hard sell in movie theaters nowadays? I'm gonna jump in real quick with a super fast answer than you guys do.
我能理解。我不理解的是，为什么人们对那种在一群人中一起欢笑的共同体验没有渴望了？所以告诉我们你们是怎么想的，你们认为为什么喜剧现在在电影院里这么难卖？我先插一句，用一个比你们更快的答案来回答。
It's because comedy now you can get on your phone in little tiny bites and you're fulfilled. And I think that has to do with it. Thanks, Sean. You're welcome. Guys, I gotta run. I gotta run. Tick tock.
那是因为现在的喜剧你可以在手机上通过极短的碎片获取，并且能得到满足。我觉得这和这个有关系。谢谢，肖恩。不客气。各位，我得走了。我得走了。TikTok。
Are you taking off? Tick tock is still there? I'm so sorry, I'll talk to you guys later. Sean Hayes, brought to you by Netflix. Yes. Exactly. That's tick tock. By the way, think about it.
你要走了吗？TikTok还在那儿？我很抱歉，我一会儿跟你们聊。肖恩·海斯，由Netflix为您呈献。是的。没错。那是TikTok。顺便说一句，想想看……
People used to go to theaters to watch porn together. That's TikTok. By the way, think about it, people used to go to theaters to watch porn together. That's true. Think about that. What do you mean, used to? That's over now. Right, Sean, that's over now, right Sean? Used to, used to. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
人们以前去电影院一起看色情片。那是TikTok。顺便说一句，想想看，人们以前去电影院一起看色情片。是真的。想想看。什么叫“以前”？现在已经没有了。对吧，肖恩，现在已经没有了，对吧肖恩？以前，以前。对，对，对，对，对，对。
But I think a lot of comedy has gone to live on streaming and TikTok in short form. However, I do think that theatrical audience is there. I thought Jen Lawrence's movie No Hard Feelings was a good shot at it. And I do think- That's one for Tom. Tom, right?
但我认为很多喜剧已经转移到了流媒体和短形式的TikTok上。然而，我认为院线观众依然存在。我觉得詹·劳伦斯的电影《珍爱硬币》（No Hard Feelings）是一次很好的尝试。而且我认为——那是为汤姆拍的。汤姆，对吧？
Is that Tom Rothman? Yes, Tom Rothman. Hey, Tom! You're back. Hey, this guy! I'm going to give Tom Rothman too. Anyone but you came out and worked theatrically. Thank you, Mike, for showing Jason up. Jason, Tom is so mad at you. You Tom movies theatrically. Thank you Mike for showing Jason up.
那是汤姆·罗特曼吗？是的，汤姆·罗特曼。嘿，汤姆！你回来了。嘿，这家伙！我也要给汤姆·罗特曼点赞。《随便你怎么说》（Anyone but You）上映了并且在院线取得了成功。谢谢你，迈克，把杰森比下去了。杰森，汤姆生你的气了。你拍的汤姆电影……谢谢迈克把杰森比下去了。
Jason, Tom is so mad at you. You Tom Moody. Tom is mad at you now. Also comedy's different now. Comedy's different than when we grew up. It's told in a different way. But I think if you had, you know, if you had, we want to bring R-rated comedy back,
杰森，汤姆生你的气了。你这个汤姆·穆迪。汤姆现在生你的气了。而且喜剧现在不一样了。喜剧和我们成长的时候不一样了。它的讲述方式不同了。但我觉得如果你有……如果你有……我们想把R级喜剧带回来……
we want to bring romantic comedy back, but I do think it's a case if you build it, they will come. We just, so much of the talent, the new talent, has gone directly right into streaming and TikTok and YouTube. We're just trying to steer them back to, look, let's take a shot with an original script. Let's take a shot with it.
我们想把浪漫喜剧带回来，但我确实认为这属于“你建好了，他们就会来”的情况。只是太多的才华、新的人才直接涌入了流媒体、TikTok和YouTube。我们只是在试图引导他们回到正轨：“听着，让我们用原创剧本试一把。让我们试一把。”
Well, we had Blum on here a while ago. Jason Blum, yeah. Jason Blum, because he, yeah. Tracy knows, because she while ago. Jason Blum, yeah. Jason Blum, because he, yeah. And Tracy knows because she heard it. And we had Blum on here because he basically forced us to have him on. And we love it, we love it, we love it, we love it. It's a joke, he was amazing. We love Jason.
好吧，我们不久前请来布鲁姆（Blum）。杰森·布鲁姆，是的。杰森·布鲁姆，因为他，是的。特蕾西知道，因为她不久前……杰森·布鲁姆，是的。杰森·布鲁姆，因为他，是的。特蕾西知道，因为她听到了。我们请来布鲁姆是因为他基本上逼我们请他来，我们太喜欢了，太喜欢了，太喜欢了，太喜欢了。开玩笑的，他太棒了。我们爱杰森。
Yeah, we love him. I couldn't love him more. Who doesn't? But we did talk to him about the, because he was, you know, he's obviously the master of horror and horror. I said, why can't we make a comedy? He said, you just can't make any money. And he was quite blunt about it.
是的，我们爱他。我不能更爱他了。谁不爱呢？但我们确实跟他聊过关于……因为他是，你知道的，他显然是恐怖片和惊悚片大师。我问：“为什么我们不能拍一部喜剧？”他说：“你根本赚不到钱。”他对此相当直言不讳。
No, yeah, we're going to prove him wrong. I'm just suspicious of blanket statements like that. Cause everybody says, so my career is 40 years now. Since 1985. You look great, Mike. Every time someone says, thank you so much, I moisturize. I think every time someone says this will never work again
不，是的，我们要证明他是错的。我只是对这种一概而论的说法持怀疑态度。因为每个人都说……所以我的职业生涯现在已经40年了。从1985年开始。你看起来气色真好，迈克。每当有人说“谢谢，我用了保湿霜”时，我都觉得每当有人说“这再也不会管用了”……
and then something comes out and proves it wrong. I remember the R-rated comedy was dead and then American Pie came out and suddenly everybody had to have an R-rated comedy. Hollywood can be such a pack animal sometimes, and I just am very suspicious of blanket statements. And reactionary too, right? Yes, very.
然后总会有新东西出来证明它是错的。我记得当时有人说R级喜剧已经死了，然后《美国派》上映了，突然之间每个人都必须拍一部R级喜剧。好莱坞有时就像一群狼一样盲目跟风，我只是对这种一概而论的说法非常怀疑。而且也具有反动性，对吧？是的，非常。
Yeah, one of the greatest things I've ever heard is everybody wants to be the second person to say yes. That's a great quote. Yeah, but it's more fun being first through the door. That's true. It just is. Of course. Look, this could be famous last words, but for better or worse, Pam and I feel like you can't do this job if you're afraid of getting fired. You gotta be fearless in it, That's true.
是的，我听过最棒的话之一就是：每个人都想成为第二个说“好”的人。这真是一句名言。是的，但第一个冲进门里更有趣。确实如此。当然。看，这可能是最后的大话，但不管怎样，帕姆和我感觉，如果你害怕被解雇，你就没法做这份工作。你必须在这方面无所畏惧。没错。
exciting new ideas. Just because it hasn't been done before doesn't mean it's not gonna work. And I just think. You could do both. You could walk into the gym at the same time. You could mine your IP, your franchises, but you can also try to find that next generation of filmmakers that'll give you new franchises.
提出令人兴奋的新想法。仅仅因为它以前没被做过，并不意味着它就行不通。我只是觉得……你可以两者兼顾。你可以同时走进健身房。你可以挖掘你的IP、你的特许经营权，但你也可以努力寻找下一代电影人，他们能给你带来新的特许经营权。
Speaking of IP, you mentioned earlier you're a big comic book collector, Mike, and so one of the things you guys get to oversee is DC and James Gunn and Peter Safran in there. Tell us what you're excited about coming out of there. Well, we actually, we have to stipulate, DC reports directly to David Zaslav. We don't oversee it, but we were big supporters
说到IP，你刚才提到你是个大漫画收藏家，迈克，所以你们负责监督的事情之一就是DC以及那里的詹姆斯·格恩和彼得·萨夫兰。告诉我们你们对那里即将推出的项目有什么兴奋的点。好吧，其实我们得说明一下，DC直接向大卫·扎斯拉夫汇报。我们不负责监督，但我们是强有力的支持者……
of Peter and James taking the job. Working concert with. Yeah, we agree that that label really could have, we thought our advice when we were asked is, Yeah, we agree that that label really could have, we thought our advice when we were asked is it doesn't need another career executive, it needs a storyteller in charge. We were really impressed with Pixar,
支持彼得和詹姆斯接手这份工作。与……协同工作。是的，我们同意那个品牌真的可以……我们被征求意见时的建议是：是的，我们同意那个品牌真的可以……我们被征求意见时的建议是，它不需要另一个职业高管，它需要一个负责讲故事的人。我们对皮克斯印象深刻……
they brought Pete Docter, who's a filmmaker, in from the field to be chief content officer and preside over their slate of movies. And James, I used to chase James as a producer you know, when he did Slither and started with his low budget movies. And he's really unique and I think DC's in great hands with the two of them.
他们把身为电影人的皮特·多克特从一线请来担任首席内容官，负责监督他们的电影片单。而詹姆斯，我以前当制片人的时候曾追过詹姆斯，你知道的，当他拍《撕裂人》并从低成本电影起步时。他真的很独特，而且我认为DC在他们两人的管理下前途无量。
We've seen an early cut of Superman and I don't want to jump the, I don't want to bury the lead. There's a lot of marketing about to roll out on the way to its release, but he really understood the assignment. His heart's in the right place, his aim is true, and we're really excited about their new version of DC.
我们看过了《超人》的早期剪辑版，我不想抢跑，我不想把重点掩盖过去。在它上映的路上还有大量的营销活动要推出，但他确实理解了这个任务。他的心在正确的地方，他的目标很准，我们对他们的新版DC感到非常兴奋。
That's cool. Yeah, James is great. It's awesome for the whole studio though too, because it allows for you to sort of cross promote, and like what is it, the rising tides? Will, what's it saying? Well, all boats. All boats rise. Right. Yeah, that's right.? Well, all boats. All boats rise.
太酷了。是的，詹姆斯很棒。这对整个电影公司来说也很棒，因为它允许你们进行交叉推广，就像那句话说的，水涨船高？威利，原话是怎么说的？嗯，所有的船。所有的船都会浮起来。对。是的，没错。？嗯，所有的船。所有的船都会浮起来。
Right. Yeah. What do you guys think about... God, you're going to love the real world at some point. I'm going to fucking... I just knew I was going to get it slightly wrong. Honestly, it's really enjoyable. It's nice that you guys have each other's backs.
对。是的。你们觉得……天哪，你们总有一天会喜欢上现实世界的。我他妈的……我当时就知道我会稍微说错一点。老实说，这真的很有趣。很高兴你们能互相支持。
I know, I love it. Yeah, it's so cute. What do you guys think about, like, remember Quibi, when Quibi came out, I would say, may have... Oh yeah. You promised to never bring up Quibi again. Come on, Sean.
我知道，我太喜欢了。是的，太可爱了。你们怎么看……比如，还记得Quibi吗？当Quibi出来的时候，我会说，可能……哦，是的。你答应过再也不提Quibi了。得了吧，肖恩。
What are you doing? Wait. Now you hurt Rothman, now you're hurting Jeffrey. when Quibi came out, which I may or may not have been. You promised to never bring up Quibi again. Come on, shut up. What are you doing? Wait. Now you're hurting Jeffrey. I didn't say anything about it. I just said, do you remember it? I do remember it. Okay, and I just read, and I didn't read the whole thing.
你在干什么？等等。现在你伤害了罗特曼，现在你又在伤害杰弗瑞。当Quibi出来的时候，我可能或者可能没有……你答应过再也不提Quibi了。得了吧，闭嘴。你在干什么？等等。现在你伤害了杰弗瑞。我什么都没说。我只是说，你还记得吗？我确实记得。好吧，我刚刚读到，我没有读完整篇。
I read a blurb about that. That's coming back now, like short, short little things, like short episodes that are two minutes long and they're really picking up and kids on social media are loving it. They want a whole season of like two minute episodes and 10 two minute episodes or something that's tell a story.
我只读了一篇关于那个的小短文。那个现在又要卷土重来了，像那种超短的小短片，比如只有两分钟长的短剧，现在非常火，社交网络上的孩子们很喜欢。他们想要一整季只有两分钟一集的剧，或者类似有10集两分钟短片的东西来讲述一个故事。
What do you think about that? Is that true and is that really picking up steam? Yeah, I personally think, you know, YouTube and TikTok and some of the platforms are really about user-generated content. And I think that's great. And I think some of the user-generated content will evolve into scripted content occasionally.
你们怎么看这个？这是真的吗？这真的开始火了吗？是的，我个人认为，你知道的，YouTube、TikTok和一些平台确实是以用户生成内容为主的。我觉得这很棒。而且我认为一些用户生成的内容偶尔会演变成剧本化的内容。
But in a way, when Quibi debuted, I'm not an MBA. I'm not half as smart as a lot of the people involved who ran that company and I would never say that I know better. I did think though, YouTube kind of has that base covered. What people really love about those platforms and short form content is that it's user generated. There's no distributor involved. It's the creator directly to their audience. That's right, and it's for those platforms.
但在某种程度上，当Quibi首次亮相时——我不是MBA。我的智商连管理那家公司的很多人的十分之一都不到，我绝不会说我比他们更懂。不过我确实认为，YouTube在某种程度上已经涵盖了这方面的需求。人们真正喜欢这些平台和短内容的原因在于它是用户生成的。没有发行商介入。这是创作者直接面向他们的受众。没错，而且是针对这些平台的。
And I think that's kind of wonderful. Yeah, I agree. Yeah, I mean, I actually do think that it was a sort of a valiant effort to try to do that and to get into that space. But I think that you're right, and I think that it seems to be one of the mistakes that is consistently made is that people try to be one of the one of the mistakes that is
我觉得这挺奇妙的。是的，我同意。是的，我的意思是，我其实确实认为这是一个勇敢的尝试，试图去做这件事并进入这个领域。但我认为你是对的，而且我觉得似乎有一个经常犯的错误，那就是人们试图去……有一个经常犯的错误是……
Consistently made is that people try to jump out of their lane and there's nothing wrong with taking chances, but they They they say well, we're now we're gonna do the thing. We're gonna try to create this and then make it into a movie Well, no, it is that it shouldn't be that it's like when they make the doc You know that documentary that everybody loved during the pandemic and then they they go, let's make it into a movie. Well, they've already got the documentary. We know the fucking story. Why are we doing that again? I think the same thing. Well, then why did you never said that then?
经常犯的错误是人们试图跨界，去尝试冒险并没有错，但他们会说：好吧，现在我们要开始做了。我们要试着创造这个，然后把它拍成电影。好吧，不，不应该是这样的。就像他们拍那部纪录片——每个人在疫情期间都喜欢的那部纪录片，然后他们说：我们把它拍成电影吧。好吧，他们已经有纪录片了。我们他妈的已经知道这个故事了。为什么还要再拍一遍？我也这么觉得。好吧，那你为什么当时不说呢？
Why did I have to say it? And then you can just agree is that you don't get to co-author this. You're the second guy in. No, this isn't why you can agree with me and say, yeah, you're really smart, but you don't get to have any ownership of it. But wait a minute, I agree, but there are examples
为什么非要我说？然后你就可以附和了，你不能联合署名。你是第二个说话的人。不，这不是因为你可以同意我的观点并说“是的，你真聪明”，但你对它没有任何所有权。等等，我同意，但确实有这样的例子……
that where that has happened, but it worked, where the documentary, I mean, with the film of the documentary is actually engaging and thoughtful and successful and, you know. I mean, sometimes when we did Captain Phillips, I did that with Scott Rudden and Dana Bernetti. The impetus was we were watching the news. You get a version of the story from the news,
这种情况发生过并且成功了，纪录片改编的电影实际上引人入胜、深思熟虑且非常成功，你知道的。我的意思是，有时当我们拍《菲利普船长》时，我是和斯科特·鲁丁以及达纳·布鲁内蒂一起合作的。最初的契机是我们正在看新闻。你从新闻中得到了故事的一个版本……
but we were thinking, gee, the news can't tell you what's being said inside that lifeboat or what the hijackers are saying to Captain Phillips. And when you can dramatize, because I did Moneyball, Captain Phillips, and Social Network all based on true stories. And the neat thing about dramatizing true stories, whether you're adapting a documentary
但我们在想，天哪，新闻无法告诉你那艘救生艇里在说些什么，或者劫匪对菲利普船长说了什么。当你能把它戏剧化时——因为我制作了《点球成金》、《菲利普船长》和《社交网络》，它们都改编自真实故事。而将真实故事戏剧化的妙处在于，无论你是在改编纪录片……
or working off a nonfiction book, is you can bring audiences dramatic structure, which are peaks and valleys and moments that you can't. I'm the captain now. And that was an improv line too, yeah. Yeah, I'm the captain now. And that was an improv line too, yeah. Yeah, I'm the captain now. And by the way, I remember reading Moneyball. That was 2003 when that book came out.
还是根据非虚构书籍创作，你都可以为观众带来戏剧结构，也就是那些你无法在新闻中看到的起伏和高潮时刻。“我才是船长。”这也是一句即兴台词，对吧。对，“我才是船长。”这也是一句即兴台词，对吧。对，“我才是船长。”顺便说一句，我记得我读过《点球成金》。那是2003年那本书出版的时候。
The great Michael Lewis. The great Michael Lewis. I've read all his books. These guys have never read a book in their lives. And I read that book. My ears work. They read book reviews though, I'm sure. But I remember thinking at the time when I heard that they were making Moneyball into
伟大的迈克尔·刘易斯。伟大的迈克尔·刘易斯。我读过他所有的书。这些家伙这辈子从来没读过一本书。而我读了那本书。我的耳朵好用。不过我确信他们读过书评。但我记得当时听到他们要把《点球成金》拍成……
a film, I thought, if you've read the book, you think, well, how the fuck are they going to do that, right? Or social network, like, I want to see a fucking movie about Facebook. It was incredible. I loved Moneyball the film. We had the, I mean, Aaron Sorkin, who's one of the, if not the best working screenwriter, certainly one of the greats on social network, and he co-wrote Moneyball with Steve Zalien, who wrote Chinua's List.
电影时，我想，如果你读过这本书，你会想：他们他妈的怎么拍得出来？或者像《社交网络》一样，我想看一部关于脸书的电影。这太不可思议了。我非常喜欢电影版的《点球成金》。我们有……我的意思是，阿伦·索尔金，他是当今最优秀的编剧之一，如果不是最棒的话，《社交网络》的编剧绝对是伟大的编剧之一，他和写过《辛德勒的名单》的斯蒂芬·泽里安共同编写了《点球成金》。
I mean, these are incredible screenwriters, and they were able to find the human story. Obviously, it's amazing. Yeah, what they did. It's brilliant. If you read the book, you realize how brilliant those screenplays are. But talk a little bit, if you don't think
我的意思是，这些都是极其出色的编剧，他们能够找到人性化的故事。显然，这太棒了。是的，他们做的事。这太绝了。如果你读过那本书，你就会意识到那些剧本有多么出色。但如果你不觉得
it's going to be a sleeping pill like my questions are. bit if you don't think it's going to be a sleeping pill like my questions are. Is there an interesting story that Tracy might be interested to hear about how, when you do a true story, how do you put the words into the mouth of real people without getting sued? Like how does Aaron Sorkin go off and say, all right, now, you know, Mark Zuckerberg says this, and then he says that. Because it's a dramatization. I know, but you're using real people. So there's legal safe harbor you can get into.
我的问题会像安眠药一样无聊的话，请多谈一点。如果你觉得我的问题不会像安眠药一样无聊的话。有没有什么有趣的故事，比如特雷西可能会感兴趣的，关于你在拍真实故事时，如何在不被告的情况下把台词放进真实人物的嘴里？比如亚伦·索尔金怎么能跑出去说，行吧，现在，你知道的，马克·扎克伯格这么说，然后他又那么说。因为这是戏剧化处理。我知道，但你用的是真人。所以你可以获得某种法律避风港。
Basically the way, not to get too boring about it, but basically if you're not derogatory or defamatory, you know, you have dramatic license, certainly to make up dialogue. You also, we do a legal vetting of every screenplay based on a true story, and it goes through this vetting process of are you on the right side of the derogatory and defamatory line?
基本上方法是，虽然听起来可能有点无聊，但基本上只要你不是恶意中伤或诽谤，你知道的，你当然拥有戏剧创作的自由来虚构对话。另外，对于根据真实故事改编的每一个剧本，我们都会进行法律审查，它会经历这样一个审核过程：你是否站在恶意中伤和诽谤界限的正确一边？
What's the risk we're running here? And can you back up things that you're alleging through documentation? On Social Network, we had the transcripts of the lawsuit that Ed Saverin brought against Zuckerberg. And if you remember the movie, that's kind of home base for Aaron, that those depositions and that lawsuit are kind of what he cuts back to as the story's being told.
我们在这里承担的风险是什么？你所指控的事情能否通过文件来支持？在《社交网络》中，我们有埃德·萨弗林对扎克伯格提起诉讼的庭审记录。如果你还记得这部电影的话，那可以说是亚伦的大本营，随着故事的讲述，那些证词和诉讼就是他不断切回的基调。
So he was on safe ground there. On Moneyball and Captain Phillips, we actually negotiated the life rights of each of the people. So we had sewn them up before the movies were shot. But then does that give them the right to then look at the script and say, no, I didn't say that or I would never say that, take it out? Or once you pay the... No, not necessarily.
所以他在那里站稳了脚跟。在《点球成金》和《菲利普船长》中，我们实际上谈判并获得了每个人物的真人版权。所以在电影拍摄之前，我们就已经把这些都搞定了。但那会不会赋予他们权利去查看剧本然后说：“不，我没说过这话”或者“我绝不会这么说，把它删掉”？或者一旦你付了……不，不一定。
They sign it away before it's written. Now of course you don't want to... You try to be responsible because you don't want people saying when the movie comes out, you know, going on a PR jihad, that, oh, this is... This is ruining my reputation. Moneyball was actually great because we made our deal with Major League Baseball and they were, they were the gatekeepers and all we had to do
他们在剧本写好之前就把版权签出去了。当然，你不会想……你会尽量表现得负责任，因为你不想让人们在电影上映时，你知道的，发起公关圣战，说，哦，这……这毁了我的名誉。其实《点球成金》很棒，因为我们和美国职棒大联盟达成了协议，他们是守门人，我们要做的全部事情就是
was make sure Major League Baseball approved the script and approved the movie. It is helpful when you have the life rights of people and you bring them into the tent, like, films just, I worked on World Trade Center, we had John and Will's rights on Aaron Brockovich, Aaron's rights on this film Freedom Writers years ago, this teacher, Aaron Gruhl, it was based on,
确保美国职棒大联盟批准剧本并批准这部电影。当你拥有人物的真人版权并把他们拉进阵营时，这确实很有帮助，比如，电影——我曾参与过《世贸中心》，我们拥有约翰和威尔的版权；在《永不妥协》中，我们拥有艾琳的版权；几年前这部名为《自由作家》的电影，基于这位老师艾琳·格鲁尔的事迹，
we had the kids involved, we changed the kids' names to protect them and their background, but it was so helpful to have that authenticity and to have that collaboration with the real people. But sometimes then your hands are tied though because it's a true story. Maybe the ending isn't as movie-ish as you might want it to be
我们让孩子们也参与了进来，我们改变了孩子们的名字来保护他们及其背景，但拥有这种真实感以及与真人合作的感觉真是太有帮助了。但有时你的手脚也会因此被捆绑，因为这是一个真实故事。也许结局并不像你所希望的那样具有电影感，
and then you have to deviate from the real story and create some weird ending. Well let's ask somebody who loves having their hands tied. Sean, would you? Yeah, so I would prefer, I would prefer a twist. Okay, okay. I'd prefer a twist. That's with the glow stick in your teeth or?
然后你不得不偏离真实故事，搞出一个奇怪的结局。好吧，让我们问问一个喜欢自己手脚被捆绑的人。肖恩，你愿意吗？是的，所以我会更倾向于，我更倾向于一个反转。好吧，好吧。我更倾向于一个反转。那是用荧光棒咬在牙齿上还是？
Or no, it pays to have their hands tied. Go ahead, Jon. Well, before we let you guys go, can you talk a little bit about what you guys might be collectively or separately excited about that's coming out of Warner Brothers that the audience can be looking forward to? Who's, you guys wanna like separately say
或者不，手脚被捆绑是有好处的。说吧，乔恩。好吧，在让你们离开之前，你们能不能简单聊聊，华纳兄弟接下来有哪些集体或各自推出的项目让你们感到兴奋，是观众可以期待的？谁，你们想不想分别说说
which is your, you can't say which is your favorite coming out. That's like asking a parent like, I know. They're all our babies. I know. But what's coming up next that you're excited about? You're excited about all of them. What's coming up? Well look, this is, you know, I'm a little biased about New Line because I started my
哪个是你们的，你们不能说哪个是你们最期待上映的作品。这就像问一个父母——我知道。它们都是我们的宝贝。我知道。但接下来有什么让你们兴奋的作品？你们对所有的作品都很兴奋。接下来有什么？好吧，你看，这是，你知道的，我对新线影业有点偏爱，因为我开始我的
career there so it's just neat for me to have it back in my life. Final Destination 6 is a fantastic theatrical experience. That trailer looks amazing! It is so much fun. It's so much fun. It's incredible. It is so much fun. And then we have Zach's movie, Weapons, which is his follow-up to Barbarian,
职业生涯就在那里，所以能让它重新回到我的生活中，对我和我的生活来说真的很酷。《死神来了6》是一次极其美妙的影院观影体验。那个预告片看起来太棒了！真的太有趣了。太有趣了。太不可思议了。真的太有趣了。然后我们有扎克的电影《武器》，这是他继《野蛮人》之后的又一部作品，
which is completely original. I can't wait to see that. And again, an incredible audience response. And Paul Thomas Anderson has made a movie with DiCaprio. That trailer is so bitchin'. It's so of its moment. audience response and Paul Thomas Anderson has made a movie with DiCaprio. That trailer was so bitchin'. It's so of its moment. You have even, I mean, we're going to drop, that was a teaser, there's going to be another
完全是原创的。我迫不及待想看这部电影了。而且，观众的反响依然非常热烈。保罗·托马斯·安德森和小李子合作拍了一部电影。那个预告片真是太酷了。太契合当下的时代了。观众反响热烈，保罗·托马斯·安德森和小李子合作拍了一部电影。那个预告片太酷了。太契合当下的时代了。你们甚至还有，我的意思是，我们要发布，那只是个预告片，后面还会有另一个
trailer. It's so unique and so of the moment, I think that's going to really blow people away. We have Brad Pitt's F1 movie. That looked incredible. It's just a fun, big Jerry Bruckheimer, Joe Kaczynski production. Yeah. On their day one. Nobody's a bigger fun, big Jerry Bruckheimer, Joe Kaczynski production. On their day one, nobody's a bigger fan than Brad Pitt. Cool it, cool it, well.
预告片。它是如此独特，如此契合时代，我认为这绝对会惊艳所有人。我们有布拉德·皮特的F1电影。那看起来太不可思议了。这是一部有趣、宏大的杰瑞·布鲁克海默和乔·科辛斯基制作的作品。是的。在他们的第一天。没有人比布拉德·皮特更狂热了。冷静点，冷静点，好吧。
It's Brad Pitt at his Brad Pittiest. It's just so, it's really amazing to watch him in that movie. And then, you know, again, as a comic book geek, I'm really up for, I think, I cannot wait for this, for the world to see James' new Superman. That's great. I'm excited, so I'm excited for all of our sleep. And we have Mortal Kombat as well, too, in the fall, which is super fun.
这就是最“布拉德·皮特”的布拉德·皮特。看他在那部电影里的表现真的太棒了。然后，你知道的，作为一个漫画迷，我真的很期待，我觉得，我等不及让全世界看到詹姆斯的全新《超人》了。太棒了。我很兴奋，所以我为我们所有人的觉醒感到兴奋。我们在秋天还有《真人快打》，这也超级有趣。
And I'm really excited for some of the stuff we have in post. I mean, we relaunched the animation division here. We launched Warner Animation to stand on the shoulders of LEGO Movie and LEGO Batman. Oh, Will, you're, I guess, not included in that, though. No, we're going to have you back. Warner Animation Group is back. It's back. Yeah.
而且我真的很兴奋于我们后期制作中的一些作品。我的意思是，我们在那里重启了动画部门。我们创立了华纳动画，旨在站在《乐高大电影》和《乐高蝙蝠侠》的肩膀上。哦，威尔，我猜你不在其中吧。不，我们会让你回来的。华纳动画集团回归了。它回归了。是的。
I think, I feel like I sunk you guys with Teen Titans Go to the Movies, which is actually a great movie if you've ever seen it. What's it called? It's a phenomenal movie. What's it called? Teen Titans Go to the Movies is a great movie. I love that movie.
我觉得，我觉得我用《少年泰坦出击电影版》把你们给坑了，如果你看过的话，这其实是一部非常棒的电影。它叫什么？这是一部现象级的电影。它叫什么？《少年泰坦出击电影版》是一部非常棒的电影。我爱死那部电影了。
No, I love that film. I hear that's great. And I convinced, you know, we worked with those writers, Aaron and Michael, they're brilliant. They're brilliant, I agree, yeah. I think James and Peter are working on a live-action Teen Titans, but... And a new Teen Titans go, I think, actually, too. Will, maybe you could read for that, you play pretty young. But we're really excited about the new animation label.
不，我爱极了那部电影。我听说那部很棒。我游说，你知道的，我们和那些编剧亚伦和迈克尔合作过，他们太出色了。他们太出色了，我同意，是的。我想詹姆斯和彼得正在制作一部真人版的《少年泰坦》，但是……还有一部新的《少年泰坦出击》，我想，其实也有。威尔，也许你可以去为那个试镜，你看起来挺年轻的。但我们对这个新的动画厂牌感到非常兴奋。
Yeah, our first movie next year is Cat in the Hat with Hader as the cat. Bill Hader. Really, really excited for that. And you know, Bill's a direct, like Jason Bateman, Bill Hader's a director that we hope to have making movies at the studio. Yeah, Bill's a great director too.
是的，我们明年的第一部电影是带有海德作为猫的《戴帽子的猫》。比尔·海德。对此真的、真的很兴奋。你知道的，比尔是一位导演，就像杰森·贝特曼一样，比尔·海德是我们希望能在工作室里拍电影的导演。是的，比尔也是个伟大的导演。
Yeah, we have Emeril Fennell's movie, Wuthering Heights next year. We have Maggie Gyllenhaal's movie, The Bride next year. So we're really jazzed about the eclectic slate we're trying to build here with the existing IP and filmmaker-driven. It is really exciting that you guys are there and doing what you're doing and the way that you're doing it.
是的，我们明年有埃默拉尔德·芬内尔的电影《呼啸山庄》。我们明年有玛吉·吉伦哈尔的电影《新娘》。所以对于我们正试图在这里利用现有IP和以电影人为导向打造的这种丰富多彩的片单，我们感到非常兴奋。你们能身处其中并做着你们正在做的事情，以及你们做这件事的方式，真的让人非常激动。
And I'm so excited for you. The success, I don't know when this is going to air, but Minecraft and Sinners, Double Barrel, Blockbuster is coming out of the gate this month. And so just huge congratulations to you guys. Oh, Jack's the best, yeah. Look man, when you love movies, it's the best job in the world.
我为你们感到无比兴奋。这部电影的成功——我不知道这会什么时候播出——但《我的世界》和《罪人》，双管齐下，大片这个月就要上映了。所以向你们致以巨大的祝贺。哦，杰克最棒了，是的。听着，伙计，当你热爱电影时，这是世界上最好的工作。
We've been obsessed with movies since we were toddlers, and to be able to do this is, It's a dream. It's a dream come true. you can tell what the films you guys are giving your yeses to so please keep keep doing that and thank you very much for joining us today you guys are my god thank you what an honor thank you guys so much we love so great so great thank you, go back to your busy day in green light. No, this is the most fun we're going to have today, so thank you for this.
我们从蹒跚学步起就对电影着迷了，能做这件事，这简直是个梦想。这真是梦想成真。从你们点头答应的一部部电影中就能看出这一点，所以请继续保持，非常感谢你们今天能加入我们，你们简直是我的上帝，谢谢，太荣幸了，非常感谢你们，我们太爱了，太棒了，太棒了，谢谢，回去继续你们忙碌的绿灯审批的一天吧。不，这是我们今天能经历的最有趣的事，所以谢谢你们。
Thank you guys so much. Thank you guys. Thanks guys. Bye, have a great day. Bye bye bye. See you later. So guys, you know, I got to mix it up a little bit. Yes, I was just going to talk to them for a lot longer.
非常感谢你们。谢谢你们。谢谢你们。再见，祝你们有美好的一天。拜拜拜拜。回头见。所以伙计们，你知道的，我得稍微调剂一下。是的，我本来打算和他们聊更长时间的。
I was just going to say, so interesting to talk to that kind of caliber of people on the show. I know. We never get to talk to them for a lot longer. I can talk to them for a lot longer. So interesting to talk to that kind of caliber of people on the show. We never get to talk to those people. We're always talking about them or about studios or about whatever. People who work for the studio, they are running the studio. They are in control of what America is seeing
我刚想说，能在节目中和那种水平的人交谈太有趣了。我知道。我们从没有机会和他们聊很久。我可以和他们聊很久。能在节目中和那种水平的人交谈太有趣了。我们从来没有机会和那些人交流。我们总是在谈论他们，或者谈论制片厂，或者其他什么。那些为制片厂工作的人，他们在运营制片厂。他们在控制美国人看到的内容
for the Warner Brothers. Yeah, really fascinating. Yeah, and they've got such good taste and usually those folks don't get hired to do such a corporately responsible job and they manage to balance the two. I'm really fascinated with how they're able to do both that. Yeah.
为了华纳兄弟。是的，真的很迷人。是的，他们的品味真好，通常那些人不会被雇来做这种对公司负有责任的工作，而他们却成功地平衡了这两者。我对他们如何能做到这两点感到非常着迷。是的。
God, you're so stupid. I'm so dumb. I know, it would be hard for me. I can't do two things at once. I couldn't do anything. I was saying, imagine if I was in charge, you think we'd have bridges and roads, if there would be nothing,
天哪，你太蠢了。我太笨了。我知道，这对我来说会很难。我无法同时做两件事。我什么也做不好。我在想，想象一下如果由我来负责，你觉得我们会有桥梁和道路吗，如果什么都没有的话，
we'd all be huddled under a tree if I'd been in charge. Yeah. How do you think you would do at running a studio, Will? I would sit terrible, I'd run into the ground one week. What about you, Seanny? I would love it. I think I would really love it too, I don't think I'd be any good at it,
如果由我来负责，我们都会缩在一棵树下了。是的。威尔，你觉得你来运营一家制片厂会怎么样？我肯定会搞砸的，一周内就会把它拖垮。你呢，肖尼？我会很喜欢。我想我也会非常喜欢，虽然我觉得我不会擅长，
but I would love it just for a week to be on the buying side, right? I think I could do it. Get to sit there and just say, yes, tell me. Yeah, and I think it'd be super fun, and like they said. I think you'd both be horrible. You'd drive everybody who worked for you crazy. Everybody'd hate you both.
但我会很乐意仅仅为了体验一周收购方的感觉，对吧？我想我能做到。坐在那里然后说：行，告诉我。是的，而且我觉得会超级有趣，就像他们说的那样。我觉得你们俩都会糟糕透顶。你们会把手下的所有人折磨疯的。所有人都会恨死你们俩的。
Knowing you both as well as I do, everybody who'd worked there would fucking hate the hell out of you. Snacks, snacks would be so good. And they wouldn't be able to tell you. Neither of you are self- aware in any real way. We'd have a gummy. Oh yeah, a gummy closet, a chips closet. Yeah, but you know what, the chocolate closet.
以我对你们俩的了解，在那里工作的所有人都会他妈的恨死你们。零食，零食一定太棒了。而且他们还不敢告诉你。你们俩都没有任何真正的自我觉察。我们会有一个软糖柜。哦，是的，一个软糖柜，一个薯片柜。对，但是你知道吗，还有巧克力柜。
Wait, you guys are talking about the snacks. Yeah. No wait, I got one. Oh, here he comes. You know, but the biggest movie that they did was so great. What was it, last year? What was it about the Hasbro, the doll? What was it? Bar? No, it about the Hasbro, the doll? What was it?
等等，你们俩在讨论零食。对。不，等等，我有一个。哦，他来了。你知道的，但他们拍的那部最大的电影太棒了。是什么来着，去年？关于孩之宝、那个玩偶的是什么？是什么来着？巴……不，是关于孩之宝、那个玩偶的？是什么来着？
Bar... No, no, no, no. No, it doesn't fucking rhyme. It's not bi, so you can't use it. It's lazy. Try another title that's got bi in it. If you wanna find a word that does rhyme, why don't you just go and look up
巴……不，不，不，不。不，它他妈的根本不押韵。它不是“bi”开头的，所以你不能用它。这太偷懒了。换一个带“bi”的标题试试。如果你想找一个押韵的词，你为什么不直接去查查
and use some help from A-bi? No, no, not there either. No, that's not a word either. Bar no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no You know what? Hang on. I'm gonna look at a word and you two, I'm gonna put both of you on stand by! Very good! Bye! Now that's a bye! SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry and Rob Armgerf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
然后从A-bi那里寻求一些帮助呢？不，不，那里也没有。不，那也不是个词。巴不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。《SmartLess》由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗勃·阿尔姆盖夫100%有机纯手工打造。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。